[Music]
controversial influencer Andrew Tate has
been banned from Facebook and Instagram
they can't cancel me they've tried but
again they failed to stop me they've
emptied their clip and I'm still alive
the bullets have bounced off most people
that make a lot of money hide away you
don't hide away I've had a hard life
even my day-to-day reality would be too
stressful for 99.9 of people on the
planet how many people out there have
such ridiculous sums of money none of
these people are getting these things by
following the path the system is trying
to make me follow those people who
follow the path work and soon die what
do you want I was the most Googled man
on the planet or Donald Trump or Joe
Biden more than Putin at the start of
the war I was that Google no matter what
they do or what law they make there's
going to be people who work harder than
you so if you're going to be a lazy
dummy watching Love Island and I'll try
and think and use your brain guess what
you're gonna stay [ __ ] broke do you
think that your attitude towards women
boom in her face is a little bit
insulting towards me Ripper up by the
neck
foreign
thanks so much for your time glad to be
here bro appreciate it man what's life
what are you doing at the moment I'm uh
Here There and Everywhere
five flights a week you know just trying
to stay above water and uh Fight The
Matrix I'm I'm enjoying
I'm enjoying this new episode it's been
quite an interesting battle with the
whole Mass cancellation thing and moving
over to other platforms and that kind of
thing and I've been massively successful
on those so I'm just focusing on that
for now and it's interesting because
you've clearly made a lot of money and
most people that make a lot of money
Hide Away of course they make a load of
money they Hideaway you don't hide away
I do the absolute opposite yeah and as a
result of that you know you've had a lot
of backlash and the media have had a lot
to say about you but what's the reason
what is it that drives you to keep doing
all these videos and putting out this
content because you don't have to that's
a good question it's a really good
question and the reason people hide is
because obviously there's a safety
element that comes with having Mass
wealth and people knowing you know you
have all these nice things and where you
are and differing opinions and there's
certainly a disadvantage to it but I
feel like I'm in a unique position I'm
in a position where I can tell the truth
on a lot of subjects that I don't think
a lot of people can
the reason I became so uh widely known
in the world I don't think it was a
magic spell I think I was saying things
that people understood and agreed with
obviously there was a
percentage of the population that
disagreed but a whole huge contingent of
the population agreed with me and I'm in
a fortunate situation where I can't
really lose my job I can't be canceled
they've tried that and here I am I'm
still all over every single social media
platform so I think I have a duty to God
to some degree to tell the truth
and I also believe that our my
children's children will look back at
this period in history and they will be
unhappy that not enough people stood up
and told the exact truth that too many
people sat there and said okay well I
know this subject is [ __ ] but I'm
scared for my job I'm scared of the HR
department I'm scared of getting
canceled I'm scared of social media
companies I'm scared of whatever so I'm
just going to sit and be quiet and yeah
if you look throughout history
there's huge proportions of the
population who were good people who
decided to be quiet because they were
afraid and terrible things happened so I
think that I have a duty to God to run
my mouth so here I am what do you think
your main message is what's the the main
thing that you want to get across to the
world my main message is to resist a
slave mind I say this all the time uh to
understand that every single thing
you're being told has an agenda behind
it or you wouldn't be told otherwise to
examine every strongly held belief you
have and try and identify where it comes
from and why you have it I sit and argue
with people I discuss things with people
and they so fervently believe a point
and I say why do you believe that so
much like do you have personal
experience no but I saw the news
why why do you believe the news told you
X and now you are desperate you will sit
here for hours arguing that point
a lot of people are completely empty
vessels ready to be programmed and I try
and tell people listen to just stop for
a second and understand that
the things they're telling you to
believe are not necessarily for your
benefit
the people who make the rules don't make
the rules
for the benefit of everybody they make
the rules for the benefit of the people
who make the rules yeah it's the game so
um telling people to resist a slave mind
and just be critically
critical thinkers keep their brain open
pay attention to things be perspicacious
that's the general theme and it doesn't
matter whether you're left right liberal
man woman Etc just think for yourself
that's the general message talk to me
about the Matrix when you say the The
Matrix are out to get you and all this
stuff who is the Matrix have you seen
the movie The Matrix I actually haven't
you've never seen a movie no I haven't
oh bro you gotta watch it I imagine it's
kind of like The Truman Show or kinda so
basically in The Matrix there's an
artificial reality a computer generated
reality and people are being harvested
for their body heat in a real world and
their their minds are are being you
their minds are being occupied by this
uh computer-generated reality and the
basic premise of the show is that their
body is being used for what is important
and they just distract their mind so
their body can stay alive long enough to
give the machines what they want
and I really truly believe that's a
perfect analogy for the world today we
live in a world where
people are being extracted for their
value their physical value whether
you're digging holes or carrying garbage
or whatever and your mind is constantly
distracted by garbage it's distracted by
TV shows and concerts and
clown world I call it clown world
because it's a never-ending circus all
this garbage they distract you with
first it's covid and then Putin cures
kovid the day he invades and kovitz
cured and it's all just a big scam from
head to toe and the reason I call it the
Matrix is because a false reality is
being projected onto humanity and they
do that by controlling narratives if
they allowed people to have critical and
open conversations about let's say covid
at the height of the pandemic it never
would have lasted three years but the
reason because they censor and delete
one entire side of the argument then
you're only left with their version of
reality and they're projecting a reality
and they do that within every subject
there are so many subjects you can't
have an open discussion on and if they
only control they delete all of one side
and only keep one side there then that's
a false Paradigm it's a false reality
and that's what they're doing and
convincing people to act in certain ways
and do certain things which are not
necessarily in their best interest or
necessarily true
uh we live in a world where I don't
think the average person realizes how
much they are lied to from the way money
works is a lie Financial systems lie
Judicial Systems lie Medical Health Care
is a lie it's all a lie it's all a scam
just go to work pay your taxes and uh
that's why I call the Matrix so what
would you say the average person that's
maybe
you know thinking oh my gosh I'm being
controlled maybe this isn't true maybe
there that there's an agenda behind the
mainstream media and the news and the
government Maybe
maybe I mean there is I mean this is the
thing you made a good point because
sometimes people say to me well maybe
there isn't agenda what do you mean
maybe how can there maybe be an agenda
behind the mainstream news you're in
charge of the world you own the news are
you going to tell the truth if you hit a
bunch of slaves and a bunch of suckers
working their asses off for pennies you
gonna tell them truth would you
yeah I mean I can't possibly imagine
that situation why the [ __ ] would you
telling the truth the truth how does the
truth benefit so what's their benefit
then they own everything they own the
newspapers the media what what is the
agenda of the Matrix the agenda is just
it's just narrative control right the
agenda's narrative control and and as
long as they control a narrative they
can control the populist to do whatever
they need them to do it doesn't matter
if they convince you to be afraid of the
common cold and stay in your house and
destroy your own business and not see
your own [ __ ] grandmother for two
years it doesn't matter if they convince
you the planet setting on fire and
Global warming's real and now for some
reason if they tax you it'll fix it it
doesn't matter what it is they create a
narrative they prevent people from
talking to counter to that narrative
they now own reality you you change all
the Google search results everything
online says a certain thing must be true
and then you use it to you weaponize it
for your own benefit whether it's higher
tax rates or more control over or
movement or giving people's freedoms
away Etc
the the world used to be based on
freedom especially in the western world
and during communism Etc the Western
World used to stand up and say the
difference between us and the Communists
is that we're free you live in this
country it's a free country it's a free
country
but that's not the truth anymore so now
that everyone's starting to slowly
understand it's not a free country you
have to replace the freedom with
something else and the only thing that
Humanity will accept in return for
freedom is safety so they say listen
you're no longer free you can no longer
say what you want to say or go where you
want to go or do what you want to do you
can't go outside for these three years
you can't do that you can't drive that
car because of [ __ ] the polarized
cabs whatever it is
but don't worry it's for your safety
we're gonna keep you safe and that's
what it is it's all a big [ __ ] scam
it's a lie the people in charge of your
world don't give a [ __ ] about our safety
if something bad happened to you
heaven forbid let's say me let's say I
got terrible disease let's say I got
cancer and I went to the NHS
I'd be waiting [ __ ] months to get
anything done but then they want to text
me four times a day begging me to take
an injection and that's for my own good
it's [ __ ] it's a scam it's a [ __ ]
scam had to tell all of us to scam it's
a lie one of the First videos I saw of
yours was about University yeah which
was really interesting to me another
scam well interesting yeah I mean I went
I wasn't very good at school and when I
was at school they kind of I feel like
at school certainly my experience is
they push you down one of two directions
it's either going to be academic go to
university yeah or if you're a bit of a
dum-dum yeah then learn a trade go to
college learn to be a builder or and for
me I thought okay well I'm gonna have to
go down the second row and you know when
I was 16 and I was doing a bit of
Googling yeah I came across some you
know interesting books like Robert
kiyosaki's Rich Dad Poor Dad yeah and it
was just crazy to me because I'm 16 and
I'm thinking there's this whole other
world about Investments and Business and
Entrepreneurship which is completely not
taught at school completely because
that's not and and it's interesting you
say that because I have this saying and
nobody seems to understand I say money's
not real
and people said what do you mean money's
not real money's not it's not real
money's not real this number's on the
screen it's not a real thing and once
you start putting systems in place that
generate huge sums of money
and once you get to the point where
money basically has no value like I do I
can go buy a Ferrari today and my bank
balance will look basically the same it
doesn't change anything so just if money
isn't real it's just numbers it's all
[ __ ] invented it's printed from the
sky it's garbage
you just have to find a way to make
people understand your value and and
yeah it can just appear from absolutely
nowhere and I went from completely broke
to hundreds of millions of dollars and I
know what you're saying in regards to
this other world because there is a
subsect to humanity it's kind of strange
when I was broke when I was on a council
estate in lewton I thought everyone was
poor
and now that I have money it kind of
feels like everyone's rich I go to buy a
plane and they're like now I'm sold out
I thought you [ __ ] sold out a planes
would you I got to buy a Bugatti and
they're like sold out I'm like just
every all the [ __ ] do all these people
everyone's bought everything like yeah
and it's crazy uh how how many people
out there have such ridiculous sums of
money truly ridiculous sums of money uh
there are so many rich people in the
world and it's kind of like your your
reality is based on your it's the Matrix
right if you're broke everyone's broke
if you're rich everyone's rich and a lot
of people have this separation I was
lucky to live in both worlds but a lot
of people have this separation yeah so
and most people in that rich world are
quite about it yeah maybe because I mean
it just as well with the media in every
movie the the jerk is always a rich guy
you know Titanic Jack's poor but the so
the narrative I don't know if it's the
same you're you group in America right
yeah but you have to protect yourself
you have to protect yourself from uh
obviously crime
is to protect yourself from governments
you have to protect yourself from
backlash a lot of people do not see the
risk reward of being so loud and so
vocal yeah I do in my particular
circumstance but yeah it'd be easier to
be quiet about certain things the only
thing more annoying to British public
about someone being rich is from being
rich and vocal about it and and that's
the case and I understand why but I I
mean I've built absolutely all of it
myself I started like I said from a
council state and Lou and I did all of
it myself and it's interesting you said
about discovering that other world
because I always knew the same thing I
when I was going to college you're
talking about the two routes there was a
levels and less B Tech yeah College yeah
yeah College b-tech like the trades or
the a level to go to university so I did
a separate path to you I was going to
the a levels to go University and I was
walking to school to college with a
couple of my friends in a Ferrari drove
past
and I said bro you see that and he goes
yeah what about it I said doesn't that
piss you off
I lost about 16 he goes why so this dude
has 400 G's for a car 400 Grand I'm
walking four miles to college because my
mom hasn't got any car he has 400 Grand
do you think he works a job do you think
he's [ __ ] behind a counter somewhere
he knows something about the world that
I don't know yeah and they were like
well he's he's Rich I'm like yeah I know
I didn't say he wasn't Rich dummy I'm
saying he knows something about the
world I don't know and I was intrigued
and it angered me I couldn't sleep for
weeks I was pissed off every time I saw
somebody with genuine money
I understood that everything I was being
told and taught and and and they were
trying to make me believe just simply
wasn't true I was like this is [ __ ]
none of these people are getting these
things by following the path the system
is trying to make me follow nobody and
everybody intrinsically knows this if
you go to a if you if you're a BP you're
at Petrol Station and I pull up in my
Lamborghini nobody goes wow he went to
school he studied hard right dude they
[ __ ] they're like drug dealer gangster
and they do that because they know that
the mo the easiest way to amass wealth
is to break the rules because the rules
are not designed to allow most people
most people to make money you can make
money within the rules of course you can
but most people don't most people who
follow the path work consume die that's
it yeah so I always knew the same thing
as you and I knew there had to be
another way I knew that just working for
money was a paradigm that that wasn't
true and then you understand making your
money work for you and you understand
de-linking your time for money you start
learning to understand these things but
eventually you build a system
and you build an ecosystem like me I
have 60 or 70 people work from for me
all around the world and things just
happen and money just kind of appears as
long as everything is well organized do
you think that it's kind of becoming
more well-known though entrepreneurship
and how to get into business now than it
was like 10 20 years ago it's certainly
easier to make money now than ever
before I think so oh it's easier than
ever before to make money I I see I meet
so many [ __ ] 17 year olds 19 year
olds kids yeah the Ecom store or they've
got some crypto garbage or that to make
quick fast money now is almost easier
than it's ever been now that has
advantages and disadvantages I was
talking to a young guy the other day and
he was 22 I think and he caught a crypto
pump he made like four million dollars
in the last Bull Run
and now all the coins have gone down
whatever he sold some he has like one
half million he's like oh yeah so I'm
waiting for the next pump I was like bro
the problem with you is you've now been
ruined for life because you're 22 you
made easy money and you think that you
don't have to ever do any serious work
you also have no skill problems with the
crypto pump doesn't teach you anything
you didn't learn sales marketing staff
management yeah stress tolerance you
need that see nothing it doesn't know
how to do anything so you should sit in
there just gambling on [ __ ] coins
waiting for the next one to pump and
he's 22 and his ass is never going to
want to get a real job and he doesn't
have any skills so I think he's in a lot
of trouble truthfully and I made that
made this clear to him so it can be a
detrimental thing it can be a bad thing
but in terms of making money it's
certainly easier than it's ever been
because we live in a global marketplace
now you can reach the world and all you
have to do is have a message worth
making people listen to the hard part
about making money today is that we live
in an attention economy you have to
Garner attention from people it's
difficult right because anyone can start
YouTube channel but it's getting the
views that's hard right so um you have
to be talented enough and skillful
enough to Garner attention but if you
can Garner attention then you can make
money I think that's the new modern way
to view the world it's an attention
economy it doesn't matter what you do if
you're getting attention you'll make
money from it yeah and I think that's
what's happening on mass it just as well
because when I first started getting
interested in Investments and stuff I
would start going on courses getting
mentors because if you want to be good
at anything you need to coach if you
want to you know you're a world champion
kickboxer yeah I'm sure it would have
been impossible if you haven't paid for
a coach absolutely right and all my
friends at the time were saying to me oh
that's so risky yeah what are you doing
and I'm thinking you're going to UNI to
study drama you know for four years and
I'm learning about property and
Investments and you think what I'm doing
is risky yeah investing in yourself
especially learning from somebody who is
already doing what you want to do yeah
is not risky and you're right the people
who believe that's risky are just stuck
deep inside the Matrix because you're
right they're going to pay 60 70 000
pounds for a degree from University
which is one completely useless
and secondly it's always kind of been
amazing to me you talked about
kickboxing if I want to go learn
kickboxing I expect my coach to be able
to fight if I want to go learn piano I
want to see my piano teacher play piano
yeah but people will go to university
and learn business from a dudes never
write a business who's broke and it's
just like it's clown world it's stupid
like
education is becoming decentralized
which is actually one of my products so
I'm going to talk about it but education
is becoming decentralized now with the
internet and the smartest thing you can
do is look at somebody's life and go
this guy is living or he's doing exactly
what I want to do I'll learn from him
that is the smartest thing you can do as
opposed to just going to these
traditional Educational Systems because
the reason University is such a massive
scam and I I said this a million times
is because it exists in a Eco chamber it
doesn't exist in Fair competition the
the reason universities still manage to
function is because they'll give
children loans to go to these schools
but you're not allowed to use the loan
for anything else if I were to say to
the average 18 year old here's 50 Grand
you can either start your own business
you can buy a crypto you can buy
mentorship from you me and other
millionaire online you can fix your
house up or your parents house up you
can buy a nice car or you can go get a
degree and you're given the 50 G's how
many people do you think would choose a
degree no nobody zero so they link the
loan to the degree so the choices are
either don't get the loan at all or get
the loan and go to school yeah which
means that the universities don't exist
in Fair competition there's no Fair
competition within the entire
educational system as soon as there's
Fair competition nobody would choose it
because it's such a terrible Choice yeah
It suffers from double inflation it gets
more expensive every year and more
degrees exist every year so the value
goes down the price goes up year on year
on year on year it's a tall waste of
time yeah but children are bored and
they think oh I get to I don't get the
money any other way so I may as well
take it and that's why the whole
educational system is a scam I actually
have my own University
um I'm relaunching I'm changing the name
and that's going to be relaunching very
shortly but I have a university that
teaches 18 modern wealth creation
methods and it's purely online and we
teach a different way to make money than
perhaps a traditional system and it's
it's cheap it's a couple it's like 50 60
a month
um
for me to take for me to get 100 000
students like I have now at sixty
dollars a month is not impressive what's
impressive is I keep them I'm giving
more value than the 60 a month they can
go and spend that sixty dollars in
Nando's or buy some coffee or do
anything else they want with it but they
choose to go to my school because I'm
existing in a fair uh competitive
environment and I'm outperforming a
university you can't do that all these
other universities can't do it because
they're all a [ __ ] scam yeah they're
probably comparing it to University
where you're literally paying 30 grand
to learn from someone who's being paid
30 grand to get 30 grams it's a solar
scam yeah whereas uh what we're doing is
is actually you know teaching people we
have massive success stories obviously a
lot of people are making a lot of money
we have all the reviews everything on
the website covertake.com but the fact
that people have a choice they don't
have to invest in my University they can
take that money and spend it on anything
else on the planet and they still see my
University as worthwhile yeah that's how
I know it's a competitive product surely
you think there's a place for University
there if you want to be an architect and
you have to study architecture if you
want to be a lawyer and you have to
study law that's fine if you decide you
I I personally never knew what job I
wanted to do these people seem to be
very passionate about a particular trade
I just wanted to have a lot of money if
you were to say look I'll pay you a
million dollars a day a whole I would
have dug a hole yeah you know I pay a
million dollars to fly a plane give me
give me a job yeah but if someone wants
to be a doctor they want to be a lawyer
go to you go to university and do it
yeah but know what what you're doing it
for don't go and study drama and end up
a dramatic McDonald's worker five years
later or go study something generic like
business or something generic and yeah
even though business is obviously a good
thing to know but it's generic and and
it's hard to apply
I mean in my experience like imagine if
I had didn't have all this money and I
had to go get a job again I'd get a
sales job because I've always been a
Salesman and uh
I I think that's a very important life
skill to have to be good at sales and to
deal with the stress and have a
commission only environment I think
these things are good but they don't
even I don't know if they even teach
sales in University do they have any
serious sales quality same yeah it's all
garbage you know they don't teach
anything important they just teach
anything they teach things that are
going to keep you inside the slave mind
and they want you to go to school and
then go to college and then go to
university and get in debt and you have
to be in debt so that now you have to
work and you're working and you're in
debt and then they want you to take on
more debt if possible in the in the form
of a mortgage which a lot of people do
which we can talk about because I know
you're the property guy massive yeah and
then you're in debt now and once you're
in debt you can't really quit your job
and it's very difficult for you to leave
the country and and now they have now
they can hold things over you that's the
goal it's all about control mechanisms
and the system is very well designed to
make sure that people are uh conditioned
to obey it's very hard for the average
person to say no to anything unless you
have millions and millions and millions
of dollars it's very difficult to even
have an opinion on subjects I have
friends with normal jobs and they say to
me in private yeah man bro I wish I
could talk at work they can't say
anything HR will wreck them they're not
an opinion you're not allowed to talk
it's just work consume die shut up
believe what you're told that's what how
it is it's clown world this is slavery I
think when it comes to the finances and
what I've heard you say about money I
think you're pretty bang on yeah I know
you've been recently canceled well you
canceled you're still everywhere on
social media they can't cancel me you're
still everyone on social media they've
tried but they can um what do you think
the reason was I mean I've seen some of
the things that you've said that are
controversial that's not why they cancel
me they canceled attempted to cancel me
because I became the most Googled man on
the planet and I had Mass influence over
the youth especially males 18 to 23 24
year old males yeah and those are the
backbone of the slave force and we
always have been and always will be it
doesn't matter if you look at modern
times or ancient times if you had to
build an aqueduct or a road or raise an
army you'd go and find the 18 to 22 23
year old Fighting age males were the
most important demographic on the planet
we're the strongest we have the most
energy we're the most capable of doing
the most difficult tasks and they try
very hard to police that demographic
specifically the reason that they talk
all this garbage about toxic masculinity
and the reason that they purport in
every single movie that men are getting
beaten up by chicks and and every single
family movie on Netflix the woman's the
smart one and the dad's a bumbling idiot
and all these different things is
they're trying to reduce the masculine
tendency to Rebel to a degree because
they want this
subsect of the population
ready to either go die in a ditch or go
work for [ __ ] nothing and they what
they don't want the last thing they want
is this subset to the population to
think because that's the subsect of of a
populist which causes a revolution
if if if millions of 18 to 25 year old
men stand in one place that's a
revolution I say it's over it's not the
women marching the women can March
that's fine but when [ __ ] happens men
have to come along and deal with the
police have to protect them women women
can March and have an opinion that's
great but actual Revolution is going to
be men because eventually it's going to
become violent and they don't want large
groups of men standing up and going wait
wait three years you just took all our
money destroyed our businesses now the
pound is falling you're inflating us out
of the market uh the housing market we
don't stand a chance of ever having any
kind of financial Independence you're
destroying our energy sector to save
Ukraine money laundering this is garbage
and if enough of them get in a big group
in London then something has to change
and they don't want anything to change
so they try and keep this population
subdued
and I'm telling them to do the opposite
I'm telling them to think and that's the
last thing they want so they decided ah
Andrew's telling the population that the
subsect of the population that we're
most fearful of to think for themselves
so Andrew has to go and they attempted
to cancel me they have failed now I have
to make sure they don't try and suicide
me that's the next goal because what
happens if you don't shut up eventually
that's what comes next so for everyone
watching a home I would never kill
myself
but uh yeah it's an interesting times
we're living in that's for sure how did
he make how did it make you feel when
you got removed off of all social media
platforms I mean were you were you upset
about it were you top cheaper up and
around I've had a hard life yeah I've
I've had a hard life I've had a
difficult
upbringing I've had uh very difficult
situations even even my day-to-day
reality would be too stressful for 99.9
of people on the planet losing Instagram
accounts or not but you predicted it
would happen as well I predicted I've
been talking about it for a long time so
there's no way they're gonna allow me to
stay on these platforms it's not in
their best interest for me to stay on
these platforms it's not their best
interest for people who watch my
products uh sorry watch my content and
buy my products to sit there and go I
don't need anything else this guy's
telling the truth I'm listening to him
I'm making more money than ever before
my life is better than it's ever been
[ __ ] school [ __ ] you any [ __ ] you [ __ ]
the news [ __ ] you I'm following Andrew
and that's why they want to try and get
rid of me it failed I moved over to
rumble now I'm on rumble.com
and uh the stock price has blown up ever
since I've moved over and I've got 600
000 Subs instead of two or three weeks
well congratulations thank you so um
that's big on Rumble it bro it's massive
on Rumble like no one talked about
Rumble right so uh they've they've
failed to stop me they've emptied their
clip and I'm still I'm still here I'm
still alive the bullets have bounced off
uh but that's the real reason they
canceled me I don't know if you know the
the story of Socrates Socrates had to
poison himself he was arrested and he
was accused of corrupting the Earth
that's why he was tried for making the
young military-aged men
of Greece think for themselves that's
not allowed you're not allowed since
it's not a human time you're not allowed
to do that and I'm I'm committing the
cardinal sin I'm saying to men listen
they're trying to tell you X and that's
garbage the truth is why
and that's why they decide what do you
think is going to happen over the next
few years with the cost of living crisis
which is not just in the UK it's all
it's pretty much all over the world
people are literally the average salary
is about 25 30 grand a year everything's
going up apart from salaries what how do
you see the next few years panning out
I'm gonna say this now and I'm someone
from a council estate I don't have a
clue how the average person is still
surviving I don't get it like 25 30
grand a year in the in in the current
world is such a tiny amount of money
it's uh
man it's about to be worse than ever
before it's going to be Have Nots and
have Yachts it's going to be it's always
been that way yeah but it's going to
become worse and worse as inflation gets
out of control as the price of assets
soar the Richer never become richer and
the poor gonna become poorer I don't
think that most people
I'm going to correct myself I know that
most people don't understand economics
as a whole they don't understand money
as a whole because if the people
watching this if they all understood how
all this [ __ ] worked they there'd be
there'd be a revolution tomorrow so they
don't understand any of it but it's very
difficult
for
a government to even
pretend to give a [ __ ] about the average
person to me because I understand how
all this works so the government comes
along and decides to give out free money
average person in the middle or at the
bottom goes wait free money government
cares about the poor person no they
don't
if they let's imagine let's keep it very
simple let's say they gave every person
in the UK a thousand pounds they're
either going to save that money or
they're going to spend that money or
they're going to let's say invest that
money
if they spend that money which is what
90 of them would do it goes to
corporations making the corporations
Filthy Rich the stock of the stock price
of Amazon during covet went to the moon
because everyone's sitting at home bored
just buying stuff right
so there's less corporations than there
are people so let's say you give
everyone the UK a thousand pounds a lot
of that money goes to one guy Jeff Bezos
the rich get richer just like before
let's say they invest it well they can
invest it in what the stock market well
that increases the price the share price
of companies who owns companies rich
people
let's say for somehow 200 of these
people are best friends and they're
never going to argue and they get
together and they get 200 000 pounds and
they buy a house for example that's
still going to raise the price of
housing on that street the house owners
the homeowners are get richer the people
who already own things asset owners are
always going to get richer no matter
what you do the people who are poor are
always going to get poorer and the asset
owners always get richer yeah and it's
it's running away now to a point where
that the chance of buying a home on the
average salary
as near on Impossible I mean you know
some hacks you know some things about it
etc etc but I don't know how people are
surviving on this money because in my I
come from a council state in Luton
that's fine but now I'm living in a
world where
I go to
I mean I can talk a bunch of rich people
stuff right here for me it's very normal
now to jump on a jet from Bucharest
where I live in Romania I'll go to
Monaco that's 30 40 Grand we'll go stay
in a hotel which is five grand a night
we'll go out for dinner three or four of
us that costs 15 20 grand uh we'll stay
we'll have a business meeting at lunch
at home I'll spend 250 200 000 pounds in
a weekend
to go to a meeting and and I'm not the
only one doing it there's 30 other guys
there doing the same thing like I don't
think people who are working normal jobs
understand that there are people out
here making such ridiculous sums of
money and that would be the hardest
thing for me if I ever had to get
plugged back into the Matrix and work
for 30 grand a year it's not not the
wage just knowing how badly I'm being
wrecked it would just I'd be like
knowing how much I'm being screwed would
just upset me but yeah it's going to get
harder and harder it's not going to get
any easier the government has no power
to legislate
money into the hands of the poor they
can take more money off the rich or they
can attempt to we can talk about that in
a second because they really can't but
they can attempt to take more money from
the rich but throughout the bureaucracy
and the the way the machine works and
the corruption inside of every
government by the time they let's say
they take let's say they take 100
million let's make it easy numbers maybe
30 million of it might end up kind of
somewhere a little bit and then we have
the same problem we discussed earlier
the poor people just spend it goes back
to the rich people yeah like it's it's
just the way the whole system's set up
the average people come to me and say
what do I do I'm just the average guy
and my only answer is stop being the
average guy
it's my only answer you can't just be
the average guy anymore the I the idea
from the 1950s that you can just be the
normal average law-abiding hard-working
Citizen and you'll have a good life is
gone any man out here who goes I'm just
going to work hard do my bit and obey
the laws and I'll have a good life no
you won't no you will not just doing
your job is never going to make you rich
because you're just gonna be taxed into
infinity and you're gonna stay broke so
just obeying laws and doing your job now
has set you up for to be a peon a slave
for attorney you have to get yourself in
a position where
you're making enough money that
I'm not saying laws can be broken but
there's there certainly can be bent I
mean I think you know this with
accountancy and and the way the tax laws
work you get to a certain level where
it's like okay yeah we can just put that
one to the side we can twist that one
around
says break the rules but don't break the
law completely yeah and that's basically
it right so you get to a certain level
and that's where it's really interesting
because the the average peon their their
answer to all this is we need to tax the
rich because they don't understand how
money Works they don't understand how
the world works and they think that rich
people are out here working some kind of
job that you can tax how do you tax a
rich guy how do you tax a rich man
firstly let me tell you something about
myself and most rich people we don't own
anything
I don't own anything I don't own
anything there may be a trust fund in
Ecuador that owns a company in Singapore
that might own a yaw that I can borrow
for for example
but I don't own [ __ ] so that's the first
thing the second thing you have all
these different jurisdictions around the
world extremely complicated how are you
going to tax a rich guy because houses
here houses there company here company
there all the companies making a loss to
Starbucks pay tax no the Starbucks
supposedly doesn't make money supposedly
Uber's never made profit an app on the
phone with millions of cars around the
world and people working endless hours
for them and I'm getting a cut of it to
run an app supposedly they'd never make
profit never paid a penny tax funny how
that works you can't tax the rich it's
too complicated you can't tax the rich
it doesn't work
all you're going to do is just drive
them into other countries if England
right now today were to announce a huge
tax on the rich the rich people just go
oh cool cool I'll base my company out of
Belize two pieces of paper [ __ ] you I
mean can I push back a little bit on
that point is that okay sure I mean you
say rich don't own anything I don't know
it I know quite a few billionaires I
don't know any billionaires that don't
own stuff all of my friends who are
billionaires earn a lot of stuff myself
included land properties
businesses and that's an interesting way
to look at so I'm when I say the only
thing I mean I don't want to work on a
public broadcast here
I guess it depends on your ethos towards
business the problem with owning
something is that it can be taken from
you
so let's look at it the American way in
America litigation is a big problem
everyone gets sued all the time
so you don't want to own anything
because if you get sued then you're
going to have to pay that debt and you
might have to sell your assets to pay
that debt not if it's a company though
if it's a limited company correct this
is the point yeah but the only thing
themselves okay it's a limit a company
owns it yeah exactly so you understand
what I'm saying yeah look at the Panama
papers yeah look at it and and then it
gets really complicated and this is what
I'm saying where the average Joe Schmo
at home has no idea yeah yeah because
let's look at Nike for example Nike
doesn't pay no the Knight doesn't pay
any tax why does not Nike not pay tax
well I'll give you a very simple version
they have two companies one set up in
Belize with a one percent tax rate one
set up in Europe the one set up in
Europe sells Nike trainers pays all the
staff pays the stores sells all the
shoes makes all the money makes millions
and millions and millions in profit the
one in Belize owns the trademark
so after a hundred million 200 million
whatever it is comes into the European
company the European company has a debt
to Belize to use the trademark of all
the profit isn't that coincidental yeah
right that goes to Belize then Belize
government comes along goes give us one
percent
nothing boom boom done tax paid it's a
little scam it's all a lie it's all a
scam the person who get [ __ ] it's
always the same it's the guy in the
middle yeah the guy in the middle is
going to get wrecked it makes me laugh
when they talk about we're gonna
increase taxes when they talk about
increases taxes they're not trying to
chase down the billionaire on his yaw
because they can't they're trying to
chase down the guy with an address who
can't move can't leave he has a Mortgage
Debt two kids and a dog living somewhere
in Sunderland and he's stuck there
they have there is a there's a cost to
benefit analysis and there's a risk
return on every action that we take as
humans if I was in charge of a tax
Authority I'd sit there and go okay
we have all these Millionaires and
they're all on Jets and they're
everywhere and there's seven passports
and these complicated corporate
structures and
will this is going to take years to
penetrate we need money now who can we
get now oh we'll get hit
some dude turn up you owe us money how
much 50. I don't have 50 Grand I'll pay
you 10. cool thanks
because he can't resist it the guy in
the middle can't resist and this is what
I'm saying about having things in your
name when you have things in your name
you're in trouble because if you say no
to that tax bill what do they take your
house
your car just take your [ __ ] so that's
why I mean I don't know about your
structure and obviously we can't talk on
open podcasts but the richest people I
know don't own anything they don't they
don't own anything yeah they're
companies will well but it can get even
more advanced than that because
companies can then still be litigated
but trusts can let me ask you a question
then what are you buying what are you
investing in right now and you don't
have to go into details I never want a
podcast but what sort of stuff are you
making a lot of money clearly where are
you dumping that besides supercars yeah
supercars are just I need to stop I have
28 supercars now it's got to a level of
ridiculous now where all the car brands
just text me hey new Lamborghini new
Lamborghini is coming what color do you
want I'm like black
but I think it's an important question
because there's gonna be people watching
this that are making a lot of money yeah
entrepreneurs business owners making a
lot of money and they're thinking look I
got this money where do I dump it where
do I put it yeah but there's money and
there's money right so it's different
because making a hundred grand a week or
100 a month is very different than
making let's say one or two million
dollars a week or
or three 400 a day it it all depends but
yeah that's the biggest problem the
actual genuine problem with the world
now is trying to find a place to put it
especially with inflation as rampant as
it is inflation they tell I think they
tell us it's nine or ten percent if you
believe that you're an absolute idiot
it's much higher than that British
pounds getting wrecked pound is getting
wrecked yeah so like Energy prices go to
the moon on top of that the currencies
inflating so just printing it because
we're trying to fix these problems
and it's difficult where do you put it
and you can put it into hard assets but
then hard assets come with a new problem
because my personal view is that I was
never I'm I want to be rich
and then I got rich
and then I realized what I actually
wanted was to be free and they're
different things there's a lot of people
who are rich
but they're not free yeah you they can't
they can't say the things I'm saying on
a podcast they can't tell a government
to get [ __ ] like I can if I were to
just buy a bunch of houses in England
and continue talking like I'm talking on
a long enough time scale they're gonna
take them this is the thing you don't
own houses that's the reason I'm not a
big real estate guy people say oh I own
my house oh you own it let's talk about
your owning that house go out and park
somewhere get parking ticket don't pay
it okay so they add more money don't pay
it again give you a court date don't go
they send a bailiff don't pay him on a
long enough time scale
it here may take two may take three
sooner or later they're going to come
with a big enough piece of paper and a
big enough bailiff and they're gonna
take your [ __ ] house they're gonna
say you owe us this money this is your
asset give us your asset you don't own
it if they can take it from you anytime
they want and that's what they'll do a
judge will get a new piece of paper
stamp a new piece of paper and they'll
take it because the governments have a
monopoly on violence
and and that's the true underpinning of
the world the true underpinning of the
world is violence we live in a world now
which is a society which is based on
violence and the absolute ground up
not many people look at that and
understand that and the government are
the only people who are allowed to be
violent and that's why they can get away
with whatever they want but everything
is violence there's a threat of violence
within everything
the reason
a police officer can give you a fine and
you don't tell them to piss off it's
because you don't want him to be violent
with you
that's it he has it always has that in
his back pocket they've always got
violence in their back pocket that's
what the government has so to sit and go
I trust the government I'm going to buy
this nice big house I just think that's
to a degree yeah you can make money and
yeah everything's fine as long as you
follow the rules I'm not saying it's not
but uh in my situation in my real world
view it's like I don't like I don't like
having someone having that kind of
control over me so to answer your
question sorry because I'm trying to be
a professional so real estate's
difficult the currency markets are trash
stock market's about to go down to
[ __ ] zero it's hard like it is
difficult to sit there with hundreds of
millions of dollars and go what do I do
with it where where does it go it's hard
and I found some solutions which I can't
say on the podcast but it's difficult
I'm gonna have to come back to the real
estate thing in a second sure because of
course I want to I want to defend really
absolutely
um so what are you buying bro just a
hint I know you can't go into detail but
like is it is it Forex is it crypto is
it business yeah you have to do you have
to diversify you diversify and then you
look for emerging markets right
um and truly I what I'm doing now at my
stage of my life is buying power so I
thought I wanted to be rich I didn't
want to be rich I wanted to be free
you're only free with power and in the
American political system is a perfect
example of lobbyists and lobbying yeah
like they will Lobby for things they'll
come along and say I'll give an example
why are there no high-speed trains in
America America's huge and Rich
high-speed trains would be fantastic for
America but the rail network is
basically non-existent the reason is
because the oil companies Lobby both
political parties to make sure that they
don't build trains everyone drives long
highways it's good sells a lot gasoline
that's what they want
so once you get to a certain level of
money you realize you want political
friends so you're like okay I want this
law or I want this law to work this way
or I just want someone I can call if
this happens to me
and you just start giving a lot of money
away effectively and you're trying to
buy Power and that's why it's always
worked that's what these huge
corporations and companies do why do you
think they're paying zero percent tax
you think we don't we could go we could
come for them if we really wanted to but
we won't because the whole system is so
rigged we can talk about this forever
but people don't understand the whole
system's so entirely rigged you and me
are both going to run for a position
we're going to go both run for let's say
the mayor of nobody of nowhere Town some
imaginary place
I've sold my soul to the devil and you
haven't
so you're an honest man and you want to
make the companies pay tax I don't give
a [ __ ] I just want Power
so the companies give me money so one I
get a nicer campaign Trail two the
companies also own all the media so they
lie about you tell the world you're evil
like they just lied about me they lie
about you to all the horrible things
they can say I'm a good person
they they [ __ ] with your bank accounts
mess with you lie with you in the media
you're trying to to run your campaign
I'm fully funded the media's on my side
tour bus posters who's gonna win
I win and then what do I do in return
for the company who I sold my soul to
don't worry about tax
but we'll just tax that dude in
Sunderland he'll pay the tax don't worry
about it
it's a scam it's all a lie whole systems
lie all of it from at the dough every
single thing is a lie
and uh I think a lot of the reason
average people don't know this or
pretend they don't know this is because
by pretending to be ignorant they they
can sleep at night because if they truly
understood it they'd be like I'm just my
life's just I'm in The Matrix I'm just
being my whole existence is a waste of
time yeah no I think the thing is Andrew
you are a straight talker right and
that's one of the things I think so many
people love about you you say absolutely
as it is and my fear is if you say real
estate's dangerous this is dangerous
that's people would not know what to do
and they'll end up doing nothing they're
getting their money in the bank that's
right help us out okay that's true help
us out when I say real estate is
dangerous now firstly you can make money
with real estate you can make money with
real estate
I'm not saying it's dangerous from that
perspective I'm talking about my own
personal ideology my personal ideology
is I don't want to be within control of
a government I don't want a government
to control me
if I didn't think that way then I'd be a
lot less opposed to real estate I mean a
house is always going to be worth
something it ain't gonna go to zero you
know it's not like a risk like a crypto
yeah uh or a stock that can go to zero a
house will always be worth something and
you can definitely make a lot of money
in it I'm just at the position where I
just don't want to have a government to
have control over me and this recent War
approved it look at all these
billionaire Russians who fair and square
bought properly in London by the law
paid their price paid the stamp Duty
stuck to the rules
then the president of their country did
something who's they may not even agreed
with it who do they know do you agree
with everything the Prime Minister does
now no neither do I and then the British
government came along just took all
their houses off here's my status if you
have gold silver anything specially
money in the bank it can if you go down
the extreme levels enough it can get
taken oh that's true nothing nothing on
this Earth is Freehold everything is
lease old to a degree there are certain
things which can't be taken like you
won't give us one example though so it's
hard to there are some things that can't
be done okay but I think that property
yeah is one of the hardest things for
them for anybody to take you can make a
lot of I make a lot of money in property
without owning it as well yeah but I'm
controlling it absolutely and also being
a property entrepreneur I I can't say
you don't make money in real estate and
I'm also not saying I don't own anything
you do own property of course I do but
I'm just saying that I don't feel
comfortable I don't go ah bought another
house yes let me sleep easy some guys do
but I think when you truly I mean you
know what I'm doing right now flipping
land and all that kind of stuff like you
know a few years ago many people said to
me oh real estate's risque I've made
millions in real estate I bet you have
it's all I know I bet you have and
through controlling it flipping it
trading it owning it completely and my
properties are a lot are in my personal
name I've got a lot in company as well
now I think I'm in a pretty safe
position now if it gets so bad that they
take away everybody's property and the
world has ended and there's this massive
plague and everybody's dead you know
what I lived a pretty good life no
completely and I understand a lot of
people will see me as paranoid and
that's fine but um I know you can make a
whole bunch of money but the last thing
I I'm currently in a situation where I
don't need money so I'm just trying to
position myself in a way that I sleep
the best as possible yeah and I don't
feel I don't feel happy with money in
the bank either I don't that's the worst
not because of even inflation like I if
I look if I load up my bank balance and
it's 87 million dollars
that doesn't make me feel comfortable it
makes me feel the opposite right because
the one day you click on the app sorry
contact customer service that you're
like yeah [ __ ] yes you [ __ ] well
just do that [ __ ] to you so it's like I
don't like money in my Banks I Don't
Like Money in a house it's hard I know
it's hard up to the first 86 000 pounds
so if you've got a couple male and then
the bank goes bust gone it's gone world
but but I think there's a lot that can
be done like um
I'll give away one of the things I like
to do just one
so I like I like personally I prefer the
idea of digital real estate
because digital real estate is not
controlled by one government
jurisdiction and it can be owned by some
obscure
entity so let me give an example let's
say I were to buy www.money.com
that's worth money if I could put
anything on there and generate money so
that's worth money I'd pay a lot of
money for it yeah and let's say that was
owned by a Singaporean Trust
boom yeah I feel safer with that okay
okay that makes sense yeah it makes
sense because now if anyone wants to
find out who owns money.com even though
I've just said it here on this podcast
they're like look it up some Singaporean
trust okay contact the Singapore
authorities who owns this trust we can't
tell you Court in Junction
years and years and years and you yeah
it's it's complicated and I I feel like
I own it more more than a house see it's
interesting and I thought my attitude is
you've got to invest in what you know
yeah if you've made a lot of money you
should invest in what you know oh
completely I don't invest in certain
stuff if I don't understand it
completely and even if people tell me
this is a great investment this is a
great coin I'm thinking I'm all good
thanks because I want to invest in what
I understand and if you understand
digital assets yeah I mean for me
personally I think owning a website or a
link would for me would feel more risky
because I can just see any minute bang
can't open it I'd rather own land where
even if there's a war and the house gets
knocked down I've still got the land I
have a shortage of land I understand you
know I understand but and there's so
many ways to yeah and that's what's so
beautiful about making money right I I
completely understand that my my block
is ideological not I'm not saying it's a
bad idea I know that a lot of money can
be made however
let me give a caveat to that oh here we
go
I do think that most of the ways money
is made on the planet nearly all of them
yeah are Ponzi schemes I think stocks
are a Ponzi scheme and when I say Ponzi
I mean that if you're in early you make
a bunch of money and if you're in late
you get wrecked money doesn't come from
the thin air money doesn't come from the
sky so let's look at crypto right A lot
of people ask me about crypto hey what
do you think about this coin what do you
think about this coin most people don't
understand that the crypto Market is
player versus player
and it's funny because these new crypto
coins launch and they start these
telegram groups these communities and
all the people who have bought the coin
are in this community and they're all
like acting like they're friends you're
not friends yeah if you bought it at a
dollar and you want to sell it at a
profit of ten dollars someone has to buy
it off you
so you're it's not it doesn't just come
from the sky you're selling it for more
than you bought it for right so a bunch
of people get in money comes in price
goes up and up and up and up and up and
up there's always going to be a guy who
bought the top yeah and it never goes up
anymore yeah and he gets screwed there's
x amount of people at the top who get
wrecked so the people at the bottom can
make money yeah it's a Ponzi every
crypto is a Ponzi all of them I could go
get 100 million dollars right now go to
England walk around and make a bunch of
money in real estate because I got
liquid cash I'll take that I'll take
that and take that I've got all the time
in the world might take me nine years
that'll go up yeah that'll go up that'll
go up that I could do it but there's
also
Bob and Sally working their ass off
22-year mortgage 10 interest rate
when we own our home Sally then we'll be
okay don't get me wrong I think that
property
um is something that can be bad I think
that buying your own home I mean I think
that the help to buy scheme is a scam
because I'm a developer okay so while I
build houses and the help to buy scheme
is not help to buy it's helped to sell
yeah yeah because basically the people
that are getting bought into the help to
buy the government are loaning them the
money they have to fight back yeah it's
only applicable to a new build it's only
applicable if you live in it yeah so the
it's really to encourage the developers
to buy a bill and Vlog off their stock
at an expensive price and then the
people that are buying it
the second that they buy it drops in
Vegas new build 100 they've got to live
in it they're in negative equity they're
they're finished so the help to buy
scheme I guess is a way of investing in
property or not even investing a way of
buying property I don't think you should
do that I think that before you buy your
own home to live in I do own my own home
yep but I only bought it last year after
making millions so I think before you
buy your own home if you're ever going
to
become a millionaire first oh no
completely there's there's so much to
say for renting because when you rent
your flexibility yeah true I think that
flexibility if we're talking about the
attention economy and we're now living
in a world where things are changing so
rapidly think of how different the world
was 10 years ago yeah ten years ago we
had Motorola razors couldn't even do a
video on our phones now now we can film
Hollywood movies yeah like it's crazy
how fast the world's changing if you're
gonna say for 22 years I'm going to live
at this address you're a dummy because
you might get an opportunity in Japan
who knows right you're a dummy to do
that so I agree I I own the house I live
in no sorry I don't an entity in a
company blah blah owns the house I live
in
that was a cache and that's only because
I wanted it the way I wanted it I want
to renovate all this I want bulletproof
glass okay just play it yeah that's why
I did it but in general yeah you should
you should renting allows you
flexibility yeah and flexibility is very
important in the modern world to get
rich to get rich you might need to have
to go here or go there you might need a
month over there you might want to go do
something in Ireland for two months and
then also another thing about renting
especially in the western economy I know
I shouldn't say this and it's probably
going to piss off your guys but it's
true there's really very little downside
to renting because even if you don't pay
your rent they can't make you leave like
it's [ __ ] clown world over here like
oh you're renting uh three months you
don't even pay your rent and you're
still [ __ ] sleeping fine yeah so the
whole thing is like rent rent is
fantastic I would only recommend renting
unless you get to the point like you we
have so much money that's why our
tenants are guests not tenants good I
like that so they don't have the same uh
well I live in Romania so we have my
tenants because I do have tenants we
have a slightly different system in
Romania or an hour late bro keep our
Packer pay but um you know what the the
the they make it really strict to try
and help the tenants but what actually
happens is the landlords directly no the
landlords become really strict with the
vetting process yeah of course as for
big deposits yeah my sister's trying to
rent somewhere she's a single mom and
the letting Edge said we don't rent a
single moms yeah right so what's
happened is it's actually her in the
tenants of course yeah so it's all the
all the things that the government do to
try and help the poor often end up
hurting the poor why don't we what did
we say earlier about about trying to
give money out the government the
government's not capable of helping the
poor and this is why it's so important
as a person you take personal
responsibility and understand you're
living in a world where the Matrix can
be cracked you can make a bunch of money
but you need to take responsibility and
do it I will sit here and say right now
on this podcast that I have hundreds of
millions of dollars and if you go to
covertake.com my website Cobra tate.com
you can sign up for a free email I have
a new an email list and I'll send an
email a day for free that will teach you
how to make money I can say that here
and of the hundred thousand people who
watch it
five thousand might sign up 95 000 will
sit there drooling and and they'll just
ignore me yeah not sign up and then two
minutes later going bro it's so hard out
here to make money just dumbasses like
you're not even trying yeah you're not
trying right you're like what we were
saying earlier about player versus
player is absolutely not really true if
it's player versus player and you're
competing against everybody else because
you are you're competing up against
everybody else all the time and you want
it also on top of that be low energy and
lethargic and lazy well then you just
don't stand a chance there are people
out here prepared to work their ass off
yeah if you're not going to be that guy
then you're gonna [ __ ] lose but
nearly all the ways to make money I'll
send a little bit earlier are Ponzi
schemes to a degree and that's what's
kind of interesting about it it's
unfortunate that certain people in
nearly any industry or any
any money generating Avenue are always
going to get wrecked and that's just
kind of how it works and that's the way
the whole system the whole world works I
mean even me man like I made a bunch of
money on the Russian ruble when I saw
the way the war was going
I made I'm 34 million dollars I made I
knew the rubles could go up that's an
all-time high now but that takes
perspicacy this is also kind of talks
into that comes into Network
the average person is not sitting around
having conversations about the war in
Ukraine and the Russian Ruble and the
financial impact of the war me and my
team and my network were different like
most people see the news they watch the
news okay yeah okay anyway
me and my team we're watching the news
okay how can that make us money how can
that make me money how can that make me
money and and it's a different attitude
I'm having endless conversations about
the financial impacts of the war in
Ukraine and whether we think that Russia
is going to win or lose and now the
Russian rubles at an all-time high the
Russian economy is stronger than it's
ever been after crashing at the height
of the sanctions when they took away the
Sovereign wealth fund of Russia which is
[ __ ] criminal anyway they they they
did that it dumped down and now it's
hired and it's ever been on a on a
currency to get a 3X yeah like it's
nearly unheard of people don't talk
about these things I'd say this another
thing I say to my to people who asked me
to go Andrew how do I get rich
and I say okay well you're probably not
going to get rich because I I bet you're
lazy but let's say you're not lazy the
number one habit that people need to
adopt and this is a habit I had for a
very long time and I've actually
recently cleared it from my brain
because I've reached a point where peace
of mind is worth more than money but
every single time money is spent you
need to identify
how your money was taken from you and I
say taken because money can't be made
money is taken because the only people
who can make money are the governments
if you're a government you can make
money you can print it from thin air or
a bank but if you're a person you're not
making money you're convincing other
people to give it to you you're taking
money from others so every single time
you spend money on anything you need to
identify how it was taken from you when
you go and buy a coffee don't just go
buy the coffee and sit down sit and say
why did I buy this coffee okay I really
want coffee yeah but then why did I go
into this store and not that store is it
bear advertising does it have less of a
line do they have seeing how do they
convince me to come in here how much did
this coffee cost six quid what's the
profit margin on that probably five
pound fifty five pounds AE probably by
the time the cup probably costs more
than the coffee the coffee's just water
how did they convince me to spend six
pounds in this place and when you sit
there and analyze and you all start to
learn little lessons about business
you'll learn about the importance of the
signage you learn about the importance
of there being no cue yeah so that if
you ever run a business I say with my
business my people all the time faster
all the time quicker yeah like I have a
couple businesses that are physical
I'm like I don't want to see a line I
don't want to see empty because it looks
bad so when there's lines you work fast
we're down to one or two people you take
your time you talk to the customer right
you keep it sometimes like always one
person like manage the line like people
don't think about this stuff no one's
gonna sit and wait in a long ask you
maybe some idiots will but people like
me won't we've got [ __ ] to do right my
time's worth money I'm not gonna stand
wait in the line so you have to identify
how your money is taken from you if you
start doing that with every single time
you spend anything ever you're going to
start to identify business opportunities
and you're going to sit there and you're
gonna have coffee and you're gonna go
you know what
they could have sold cake and they
didn't
could I out-compete this place let's
imagine I had the money to start coffee
shop right next door how would I out
compete them well I'd have cake because
they don't have cake also most people in
here are businessmen
and this the guy serving some dude no we
need a cute waitress his ass is fired we
need a chick put a chick here put some
cake in uh Financial Times business
people in think people don't even think
about this stuff they don't use the
brain ever they don't ever look around
and realize how they're loose spending
their money they don't look around and
look at which businesses are successful
they don't look around and pay attention
to anything they don't look at the world
and all the things are happening and how
it can benefit them none of it they
don't look at any of it they're too busy
following the circus this is why it's
clown World they know all about the
football results right they're all about
Rihanna yeah and all about that crap all
about love Island they'll talk about
love Island all day the same people who
will March and [ __ ] for labor saying
oh the Tories are bad labor labor watch
Love Island at night no wonder you're
broke you're a fool you're a dummy and
no matter what the government does no
matter what a government or a financial
system no matter what they put together
it's always going to be competitive to
some degree
unless it's communism which has been
tried and they're trying to bring back
and we know how that all ends communism
ends very very quickly in violence
because there's no other way to enforce
anything
but no matter what they do or what law
they make there's going to be people who
work harder than you and they're going
to make more money than you so if you're
going to be a lazy dummy watching Love
Island and not paying attention every
time you spend money and not try and
think and use your brain guess what
you're gonna stay [ __ ] broke yeah and
and and I'm also going to say this now
I know for a fact when I talk about how
the world works and people say but why
would the people in charge do that and I
say because they view you as scum and
the reason they view you as scum
is I can say this and I'm not saying
this in a horrible way I'm from a
council estate right I came from
absolutely nothing
and I'm now at my position in life and I
know how hard I've worked
when I meet somebody who's whatever 50
years old and they have absolutely zero
money I don't think oh he's had a heart
I thought
you just didn't you're just lazy I don't
your sympathy disappears after a certain
amount of time when you can when you
pulled it off you pulled it off I pulled
it off when you've been through x amount
of [ __ ] to pull it off and everyone's
just coming out with excuses all the
time sympathy vanishes yeah look I'm
sorry I don't buy your [ __ ] right you
you did you're too busy sniffing
drinking pints doing all this dumb [ __ ]
I wasn't doing it I don't feel sorry a
few people and uh that's what happens
after a certain amount of time so if you
think if I feel that way and I'm also
from a council estate imagine these
people who were born as billionaires how
do you think they view US you think they
give a [ __ ] about record on currency I
don't give a [ __ ] you better find
something to eat on the floor they don't
give a [ __ ] this world is this world is
so much cooler than people understand
I I
I I've had people all the time come to
me saying yeah I want to make money go
take a half an hour and learn about
fractional Reserve banking learn how
even how the you don't even know how
money works yeah you don't even know how
a bank works like how you gonna make
something you don't know what it is
right like it's it's crazy man one of
the first Tick Tock videos I saw you do
was where you talk about how money is
like water and that I thought was a
really good analogy because money is
always moving yeah
um and that's again coming back to
property because you know how much I
love I love real estate of course is
if you look on the Sunday Times which
list yeah 90 of them either made their
money through real estate or made it
through business or otherwise and are
now investing in real estate of course
if you can get around people that are in
the property Market yeah even if you've
got no money being in that environment
let even if it's okay to finding deals
passing them on to the investors it's
where the money is completely oh no
that's completely utterly true and and
yes the cycle of precipitation right so
a cloud comes it rains it falls down to
the ground it goes underwater under the
ground whatever goes into a stream it
moves into the stream goes to the ocean
evaporates again up into a cloud floats
somewhere else falls down again it's
always moving that's how money is people
think that money is in these large
stagnant pools hidden hidden in people's
bank accounts that's not really true
money is constantly moving all the time
and if you can find a way to get in
between it and stand in the right place
at the right time you're gonna get wet
that's absolutely that's awesome analogy
but it's true I'm gonna steal it by the
way you can it's no problem it's true um
and a lot of people have done that right
I mean
even the little example I was talking
about earlier if anybody with a brain
didn't invest in pharmaceutical
companies at the beginning of covid I
mean you didn't buy a stock in Abbott at
beginning of covid I don't know why if
you didn't invest in the arms companies
at the beginning of this forever War I
don't know why like it's easy where's
the money going to Ukraine to buy guns
so what am I going to do I'm going to
buy stock and Raytheon like it's it's
not complicated stuff it goes into also
we'll talk about um Network and how
important that is but it's interesting
to say about being in the room where
people are making uh are talking about
appropriate deals I say the same thing I
say this to people I say
if you're in a room full of ice cream
experts ice cream and all they talk
about is ice cream how to make ice cream
their favorite flavor the best way to
store it how much it costs to produce
how to transport it and that's all they
talk about is ice cream even if you have
no interest in ice cream
over a long enough period of time you're
gonna end up knowing stuff about ice
cream you're not knowing [ __ ] you're
like Ah that's double chocolate this it
costs this much and this is how they
moved it then you're gonna know things
about ice cream
if you're in a room full of people who
only talk about money
then you're gonna end up knowing about
money it's exactly the same thing and
network is net worth everyone
understands this and people also
understand that they're likely to become
the sum of the five people they spend
the most time with yeah but then they
hang around with losers
it just blows my mind it's like I I'm a
busy man like I don't have time all
these opportunities I've given a little
away I've told a little bit about domain
names a little bit about uh the Russian
Ruble a little bit about uh stocks Etc
I'm very busy myself but my network I I
have I have hundreds of people who I
talk to all doing this [ __ ] hey Tay have
you seen this boom and I'll throw him
something he'll throw me something that
that's my ecosystem that's who I talk to
those are my friends we don't talk about
Rihanna we don't talk about the football
we don't talk about love Island we don't
talk about anything other than money
yeah how are we not going to make
hundreds of millions of dollars how are
we not gonna how am I not gonna have
money like that's all we talk about it's
all we do
so I say this video you want to say
when's the last time we talked about the
coffee shop example
says to people all the time when's the
last time you sat and talked about money
what do you mean when's the last time
you sat down with someone
and talked about money what do you mean
talk about money well if you don't know
what to talk about then you don't
understand money so go learn how money
Works go learn how Bank Works go sit on
YouTube for free you don't just pay 50
Grand in four years at the University go
sit on YouTube and understand money
banking or the real estate market any of
it understand the last housing price
crash why it happened understand
mortgage rates and how this affected by
interest rates understand it and then go
sit with someone else who understands it
and talk about it
oh yeah yeah yeah I should do that yeah
yeah
dumbasses so like they did it's it's I
don't want to be a negative person
because I'm not but to a degree I I
think the universe is very giving
and I've yet to experience in my 36
years
a man or a woman who genuinely tries
their very best
and genuinely dedicates himself to
something and is genuinely motivated to
make sure that the best version of
themselves who doesn't get what they
want yeah I've never seen it I've never
seen someone go I spend all of my time
doing what I'm supposed to do I do not
waste any of my time I dedicate myself
I'm good to people I'm honest I'm hard
working I'm there on time every time
I've got a meeting I've got a firm
handshake I don't snake anybody God
likes me I do I work hard I'm not an
evil person and I work really really
hard who doesn't have everything they
want yeah so like so you can everyone
can have anything they want I really
believe the universe will give anyone
anything they want if they actually
[ __ ] want it the problem is I think
when people complain so if someone's
complaining that they're broke and being
negative oh it's really hard but then
they're not doing the very basic things
it'd be like me complaining that I'm
overweight yeah yeah if I was to [ __ ]
about it oh by the way it's really hard
I heard you say actually on um on on a
rumble video you said that if you woke
up fat within a couple of months you'd
be slim
absolutely of course you would be and in
the same way if I broke up if I woke up
broke a couple months I'd be rich yeah
that's right yeah so it's all about
exactly you get what you want completely
and and what you push towards completely
and and that's what I I truly believe
that the universe is giving in that way
but it is player versus player and
that's just the way it works but that's
why also network is so important so a
lot of people who don't have when you
were saying earlier about being around
the property deals just even being
around people with money it's just a
good place to be I'll give you an
example I was in Romania and I have the
largest car collection
probably in Romania I have 28 supercars
everything you can name and I went to a
town called clujnopoca it's on the
border of Hungary and I drove there in
my shiron and I parked up and a kid came
up and he said hey can I take some
photos of your car I have a car spawning
page
I was like yeah whatever cool and he
goes uh
yeah okay I'll just be a few minutes of
this we took a bunch of photos and he
goes and he come up to me and say do you
want the photos and I was like not
really I've already fos and he goes oh
yeah okay um well if you want him here's
my email address and I said to him why'd
you do this like you spend all day
standing around taking photos of other
people's cars is that not a waste of
time I thought it was a waste of time
but I was wrong he goes oh well I
skipped school and I skipped College
because I knew if I take pictures of
expensive cars and and email them to
people I'll have email addresses of the
richest people in Romania yeah small I
was like you're clever I ended up hiring
him he works for me now yeah I was like
you know I like you he got himself a
full-time job that day
so he understood be near the money I
have no money money's over there well
let me get closer to it
if nobody's staying over here on my
[ __ ] own let me at least get closer
to it that was a 17 year old kid now
he's making 10 grand a month in Romania
for me so like at least being closer to
it so that you're right people should
even if they haven't got a penny in the
world should be going to these meetings
about real estate about investing that
especially if it's cheap they should go
just meet other people who at least have
money have conversations about money
talk about it how are you going to get
what you don't talk about it's it's like
you use the gym analogy it's a Perfect
Analogy I've never met anybody who is in
fantastic shape and you say how do you
get in fantastic shape and he goes
oops
don't know bro oops no absolutely not I
went to the gym every day I ate this
particular way I had a meal plan I diet
nothing is going to happen on accident
yeah this accident this mindset of when
my ship comes in one day my ship one day
it's just gonna we're gonna win lottery
maybe and it's another thing that's
actually funny talking about win the
lottery I used to dream win lottery bro
how much is the lottery win nowadays it
depends on the win it could be anything
six seven
no not yours I don't know anything about
the lottery because I think it sucks but
man like I used to dream when a lottery
think that my life would change and now
like six seven million that's a that's a
year that's a year of jets that's
nothing like it's not even money anymore
it's crazy how the perception but if
even if you win the lottery 90 of
lottery winners within 10 years are in
the exact same situation completely
because because they think it's a lot of
money it's not even a lot of money a
couple of six seven million pounds is
zero in the real world it's zero but um
yeah like it's it's it's it's
interesting but
yeah you have to be near it and your
network needs to be important and this
is the reason why and I will do a
Shameless plug here
like you have your speaking events I
think absolutely everybody should go
even if they have no intention of buying
a house they should be at that [ __ ]
speaking event they should be listening
to you and understanding how the real
estate market works and they should be
polite to people and courteous and nice
and they might make a friend and they
should sit and talk to their friend
about real estate that cannot detriment
your life now cannot detriment your life
you're gonna you'll sit and meet with
your friends on the pub and talk crap
but you won't sit and talk about money
you're not going to get it on accident
your ship's not going to come in on
accident you have to plan for this
that's why the only two things I sell
online
and trust me I've been offered endless
things I State this as a matter of fact
not a matter of arrogance I was the most
Googled man on the planet I was the most
I was the most famous individual on the
planet more than Donald Trump more than
Brad Pitt more than Joe Biden more than
Putin at the start of the war I was that
Googled when my Tick Tock thing blew up
and I was offered
30 40 million dollars to promote crypto
10 million dollars to promote some
[ __ ] pills some supposed to be some
supplement that makes you strong scam I
was offered endless money to sell my
soul and I didn't do it because I didn't
like the idea of a kid who really
believed in me and who's a fan of mine
buying a crypto because I said it's
going to go up and like I said player
versus player someone's gonna lose and
that kid losing all his money because
you know I'm in first and I own most a
coin or whatever whatever I didn't want
to be a scammer for money because I
believe that having a pure heart and
living true under God is more important
so I never sold my soul I'm not like
Logan Paul and these [ __ ] who sell an
energy drink full of sugar and crypto
pump and dump scams and nft scams and
all these other influencers sell scams
or they sell gambling to kids on their
twitch screens I don't none of that I
don't do anything only two things I sell
are my University which I have priced so
cheap 60 bucks a month so cheap that
anybody can join there's no one who's
too poor for that yeah and it's there's
no contract it's a month on month
enrollment you can join if you don't
like it you can leave everybody who
joins makes more money than they invest
look even if you if you spend 60 bucks
to join and you make 300 bucks the first
month it's still a win yeah it doesn't
matter you're not going to be a
millionaire overnight but it's still a
win it's my University
for that and although the only other
thing I have is my network which is the
war room and we have about 4 400 men
around all around the world and those
are people that's a place where you can
go and talk exactly about the things you
talk about money oh the war in Ukraine's
happening how can this make us how does
this affect me in a way that actually is
going to benefit me you know what the
news is saying the news is talking [ __ ]
about how we have to save Ukraine and
[ __ ] money laundering all this money
through [ __ ] arms companies they're
lying to you how is what's the actual
truth and how can this actually benefit
me
so I have the War Room my personal
Network there's only two things I sell
to the world I sell how to make money in
a university and I sell a network
because if you have those two things you
can have anything you want yeah and it's
interesting as well because anybody that
says I won't pay that 60 pounds because
it might not work
no but it's crazy no but what will
happen is when they go into business
they'll think they're saying and anyone
in business has to look at the best case
and the worst case and the likely case
and if anyone says well the worst case
is I'll lose 60 pounds yeah the best
case is I'll be financially independent
travel the world but you know what I'm
not going to take that risk they'll
never win in business the uh the
unfortunate reality about the world is
the law of averages and sure that half
the People You Meet are even more stupid
than average that's just the way it
works yeah you're right what kind of
stupid equation like I said I've sat
here on a podcast and said me as a
multi-millionaire even if you don't even
60 pounds I have a free email list I'll
give you tips for free Cobra tech.com
sign up we'll take three seconds and
you'll get tips on money every single
day for the rest of your life for free
they still won't do it and then you're
right what kind of idiot sits there and
goes this guy has hundreds of millions
of dollars
he doesn't need my why would he scam me
at 60 pounds surely and all these other
people are enrolled and they're paying
every month so obviously they're getting
value obviously they're making money
from this
hmm yeah but maybe I'll lose the 60
pounds of catford and Nando's not worth
it
these people just deserve to fail and
that's why I get to the point where I'm
semi-jaded I don't feel sorry for these
people they deserve to fail if you want
to make money I'll tell you how you go
to Cooper tech.com sign up for the email
list and go to join houses University
and if you want a strong Network during
the War Room there's there's all your
answers I fixed all your lives but if
you're gonna sit there and just sit on
your ass and don't do anything then
don't come up to me in the street and
ask me why you're so broken
because there's the answer to it but
yeah it's interesting man it's the
world's kind of a crazy place and
I mean the last three three years have
proved it Etc but the Matrix you have to
watch the movie The Matrix I will have
to watch it but Morpheus says it most
people's minds are not ready to be free
most peoples are so dependent on the
system that they'll fight to defend it
their minds are not ready to be freed I
also think another thing that's kind of
interesting is the world is changing so
fast in real time I think a lot of the
advice based around making money is
severely outdated yeah yeah and that's
why my University we don't have a real
estate section you're used to that I'm
sure we had something I've seen uh we
had like an Airbnb kind of thing right
we don't do real estate so much anymore
we teach 18 modern wealth creation
methods so the new stuff right because a
lot of the things people are told about
how to make money was accurate but it's
no longer accurate yeah yeah like your
parents will say hey you need to save up
and buy a home well okay when you were
saving up and buying a home it was 50
grand for a house you were earning 20
grand a year you were getting five
percent on your savings and you bought a
house and now that house for 50 Grands
worth half a million I'm sure it worked
out great for you it's a bit different
for me it's not the same so all the
advice they're giving you [ __ ] that's
the case of any business though it gets
out diet it gets outdated you need to be
and you have the modern ways which is
fantastic but I'm saying a lot of people
will sit there and listen to their
parents and I was like your parents
don't know anything your parents your
parents did something that worked once
and it doesn't work anymore and what
works now won't work in 20 years yeah
that's why you have to be perspicacious
you have to be adaptable you have to be
indefatigable you have to be you have to
pay attention to these things and this
is why network is so important this is
why you have to be talking to people who
are constantly on The Cutting Edge I'll
say this now if you're sitting here at
home watching this
you're on the internet and you're saying
I want to make money and internet know
that me
a man hundreds of millions of dollars
and my network of 4 000 people all
around the world from Singapore to
America et cetera with a combined
combined assets of billions are talking
for 12 hours a day about how to generate
money on the very cusp of culture on the
very cusp of updating geopolitics this
is who you're competing against it's
player versus player you're sitting
there like a jackass
scrolling around a little bit and going
well I hope I'll be rich one day and
there's people like me and my network
out here and and here's your competing
against you're gonna get [ __ ] wrecked
you're gonna get crushed either join the
winning team or stay broke yeah there's
no other way like you find somebody who
knows what they're doing as you do
you've proved it you have all the
credentials to proving what you're doing
I know what I'm doing and join their
team or stay broke you're gonna get
[ __ ] crushed it's it's it's player
versus player you're not gonna do it on
your own the whole idea of like this
Lone Wolf [ __ ] is also garbage you need
a network you need people you need teams
you know this better than anybody yeah
and it's like you know if you're playing
if you're playing chess I know you you
love chess and your dad was a champion
chess player and you don't really know
how to play and you're against the
champion chess player every time you're
going to get spanked and that's the
interesting thing about Chess that's
what's so great because
the rules of the game are the same for
both players the constraints are the
same but the Grand Master will destroy
you within the same constraints he can't
do any moves you can't do but he will
wreck you because he knows the game
better yeah that's all it is he knows
the rules better this is business sales
marketing Finance operation he knows it
the same and and and man most people
have no idea how to make money so I had
a guy come to me
and he was a guy and he started dating
some semi-famous girl with a big
Instagram account she was really pretty
she was out of Serbia and he come to me
and says bro she's big in Serbia I want
to launch a makeup brand
okay fair enough he goes yeah why don't
you make a brand data but I need money
it's like how much you need because I
need a quarter of a million
and I said listen
here's what we're gonna do
what's your plan you get a quarter of a
million to do what he goes well I'm
gonna build the website how much is that
going to cost I'll probably get that
done cheap in survey like two grand okay
that's a good start because then I'm
gonna buy all the stock
I was like okay and I'm going to base it
Serbia in a warehouse so I can sell it
out fast same day delivery
it's like okay fine let's do something
else instead instead of wasting all my
money
how about this here's my advice to you
because otherwise I'm going to want a
big percentage of the business that's
the first thing second thing there's a
big chance my money gets wasted so
here's what we do
I'll give you two grand make the website
take the pictures get the product
designs
put it online
[ __ ] put all over her Instagram launch
it start selling
after a few days send everybody an
automated email saying sorry we have a
delay in shipping because it's a new
brand and it's been so fantastic we're
gonna give you a free lip gloss
delay everybody and keep them happy take
in all the money buy the stock with the
money that comes in with the new money
so you're never in debt to anybody
you're not in debt to me either
buy the stock fulfill
the margin on makeup is 89 100 203
anyway give them a free gift so they
shut up or offer them a discount code
for their next order they'll be happy
and buy more yeah start your company
from nothing right and be rich see
that's the opposite of what university
teaches complete opposite complete
opposite what's funny is
he goes okay I'm gonna try that you
tried it
and he launched and nobody bought and I
said aren't you glad well I'm glad
thank God I'm glad but imagine it was
your own money aren't you glad you
didn't waste the court of a million
right you're gonna you're a dumb ass
nearly lost the score of a million
dollars yeah but now you realize it all
her followers are fake so
Eureka at least you found out cheap yeah
see I can't remember the term for that
they take they do teach that at Harvard
University which cost half a million
pounds by the way wow
there you go everybody but but this is
another thing that's interesting I think
there are so many businesses especially
in the modern Digital World which can be
started effectively for free yeah it's
different if you have to get a sharp
premises that's different fine
understood but you start with an online
shop right but yeah there's so much
stuff that can be done almost for free
people think they need money to I need
to I need money if I had money I'd start
business tell me your business plan and
let's find a way to do it for pennies
there must be a way if people want it
yeah you can sell it you can like do
that part first yeah you can do that
nearly anything but yeah here's a
question for you then so we've talked a
little bit about how to invest money and
you've given some you've given a bit
you've given a bit away which is great
um slightly different views yeah but
that's okay talk to me about not making
money because you don't believe in
making money no you believe in taking
money yeah you're starting again from
scratch you're dumped in a random City
by the way you know I don't know if
you've seen I I do this regularly I
heard I saw on YouTube yeah yeah yeah of
course you did right
what do you do starting from scratch
you're in London you've got nothing
you've got no contacts you're not in
your war room yeah and you need to make
10 000 pounds and if we if me and you
have a challenge let me ask you a
question if we had to make ten thousand
pounds from scratch drops in London he's
good we're in Disguise because you're
pretty famous yeah I'm pretty famous
he's gonna make the 10 grand first
that's a good question I'm saying me
yeah well you've done it a few times
I've never done it before however you'd
have to start with selling something
yeah you'd have to start with becoming
the middleman of something and you have
to start by taking a commission that's
the first thing you could do
to like the London dropped in the middle
of zero and doing it physically I'm not
sure I think no matter where I was
dropped I would turn to the internet no
matter what okay I think that because
the internet's just a global Marketplace
it's just so much better
I would
I'd find somebody with okay so let's add
nothing right I'd find somebody with
star power like you for example I come
along I drop you an email and say listen
I want to put something together I
believe I can help you sell more
I am hoping if I show you I can sell
more you'll give me x amount of
commission x amount percent I understand
you have star power you have something I
don't have you can talk in front of a
camera you can attract people you can
entertain people
uh what are you currently selling you're
selling this okay if if I bring x amount
of thousand people will I be able to get
this percent that's what I would do I
think that if if I didn't have the
ability to sit on a camera and entertain
I would find somebody who does and I
would be the blood and guts beneath the
show business interesting and that's the
easiest way to get rich in the world
today so you'd find someone that's got
an existing product or service correct
and then you would help them sell it and
promote it absolutely and early that's
that's the easiest way to get rich today
especially because commission only
nobody's afraid of saying yes to
nobody's afraid of being saying yes too
so let me see if I have my business
cards with me if I don't have I'm gonna
be a bit upset let me give you an
example of my business card because it
shows it perfectly so I do here we go so
here's my business card we'll just show
the camera online keep keep this Bros
for you
um but my business card
take Enterprise is unlimited kickboxing
world champion Master and Commander of
the War Room yeah also says on the back
my unmatched first Picasso a couple was
sheer into fatigue ability makes me a
feared opponent in any realm if you know
which is my saying it's a saying from my
father but it's basically saying
unmatched perspicasses the ability to
always pay attention perspicacy's
perception so unmatched I'm always
paying attention to everything all the
time and sheer into fatigability I don't
become tired makes me a feared opponent
any realm of human endeavor so a man who
always pays attention and never gives up
is a feared opponent no matter what no
matter what you're fighting against him
and then it says I specialize in the
following
wars fought assassinations plotted
Revolution started Uprising squeld
smuggling passport allocation
ventriloquist decentralized Finance
blockchain analysis whiskey Merchant
tiger taming it goes on and on and on
the point I'm making is Rainmaker
if you come to me with a billion dollars
and say put a rock on the Rock on Mars
I'll try yeah pay me okay maybe I'll
call Elon and give him 900 million to do
it maybe I'm just a middleman but I'm
the guy you can come to for anything I'm
that guy yeah no matter what you want
done I'll get it done I know a guy who
knows a guy
and I think that that kind of shows my
point overall if I had to start going to
do the same thing I'd meet people who
are extremely competent and extremely
good at what they do
you'll often find in life they're people
who are best at what they do aren't good
at the marketing and sales side of
things there are so many Fantastic
singers or [ __ ] uh painters or
whatever they're amazing and they don't
make any money they're crap it the main
the marketing the sales the whole for
moose of it yeah I'd do that it doesn't
matter if I find a singer and say look
I'm Gonna Get You bookings I want this
percent I'm gonna be the best bookings
bang I'm gonna put together a promo
video today I'm going to use my camera
guy boom I'm gonna make this excellent
and we're gonna get some personality
involved and you're gonna go up to some
random girl on the street and you're
gonna sing this is all the top of my
head you're going to some random girl on
the street and you're going to Boston or
sing to her and she's gonna we're gonna
get we're gonna do over and over again
even though a bunch of them will call
you weirdos to get one who looks like
she falls in love right there on the
spot and that's gonna go viral on Tick
Tock I'm gonna put that on your
Instagram account your Instagram
followers and when you're starting DMS
the Instagram account I'm gonna reply to
them I'm gonna book all the bookings on
the X amount percent but this all
[ __ ] okay now I got a singer out
there working I got a photographer out
there working we've got paint and paint
or she's out there painting [ __ ] bang
bang bang bang bang bang it's just the
game unless they get rich I think you do
well would you be down for a challenge
who can make the first 10 grand from
scratch cheat I can't I can't walk the
streets anymore maybe we can get a mask
design a mask when I walk the streets
it's I have to have full security teams
or the strap if I can find a way to
completely disguise you oh I don't know
that I'm top cheating on me bro your
accent would give it away yeah like yeah
like London's a bit of a weird one for
me because um
London's not safe anymore one and two
like like when I'm in Romania I'm armed
and I have a full security detail and
blah blah and when I'm in when I'm in
London it's unusual because
people recognize me and they they want
to some of them want to be friendly but
when I see full-grown people like
running up to me or coming up to me I
don't I've had a hard life right I don't
like when three full-grown men go hey
Tate
like I just don't like it so I have to
have security team people do you get
pretty mobbed in the streets oh bro it's
crazy I don't know if you've seen
there's a couple some videos yeah like
if I walk into a hotel and someone sees
it puts it on Instagram or Snapchat and
they work out to me there's just
thousands of people outside wow it's
crazy it's really nuts and that's
because like I said I've I've inspired
the masculine youth a lot so a lot of 19
year olds have nothing else to do but
try and get a picture of me and then and
that's another thing because you look
bad when you say no sometimes I say no
to guys and they're like why it's like
because if I do I do 500 photos a day
like 500 times three minutes it's like
it's my life it goes on all the time and
it's easier with Securities because Siri
can just say leave them alone because
I'm trying to live normal life right but
um it's not too bad in Romania but in
London also
it's not necessarily a safe place I'm
obviously an extremely rich person and
yeah I don't like when people run at me
and come up to me and try to surprise me
and I just want to be left oh my
question for you then when are you gonna
because you need to do an event bro
start doing it you can get your security
it can be all controlled in London Dubai
even Romania yeah so yeah yeah it's fun
is it fun it's very fun yeah I've never
done a speaking event but I actually
have my first one booked I'm doing my
first speaking event in Dubai
I've chosen to buy for security reasons
and a bunch of other reasons I believe
some Tobias the city of the future
I'm heavily invested in Dubai I love to
buy I have a lot of money to buy so um
yeah I'm doing a speaking event that's
awesome yeah I'm gonna do a speaking
event dividing my first ever one and
we'll see how that goes I think you'll
do really well at that I'm okay at
talking so we'll see uh that'll be fun
it'd be good to like meet people and do
the event and in a controlled Manner and
talk to everybody and that's that's not
just on money that's basically on My
Philosophy that's going to be a life
philosophy event on on my tenants for
Life as a whole so it's going to be
quite interesting to do and also um
yeah the Matrix try and cancel me and I
keep getting bigger and bigger right so
I've got incredible I gotta fill a
stadium all over social media not just
Rumble you're on Tick Tock you're on
Instagram after being canceled yeah
interestingly when you first got
canceled I watched your video which I
actually thought was a bit weak you
think a little bit yeah a little bit
well I I I'm very tame it looked like
yeah it was very tame I liked you I
liked the one that you did on Rumble
after that one that was that was a
little bit better yeah no I I came
across team because a lot of people are
confused about me not because of what I
say but because of the way I say things
yeah so I came across team on purpose to
try and uh alleviate you don't want to
be misunderstood yeah and uh
it's fine but um
all in all I knew that what happened
would be good for me I knew that this
was going to be a good thing
by chopping out my by chopping off my
tongue they don't prove me wrong yeah
they proved me right and I think we're
coming into a new age of Consciousness
and a new age of Truth where
a lot more people are starting to
realize still not enough but more are
starting to realize how they're getting
screwed and how they're being lied to
and that's good for people like me I'm
heavily leveraged against
chaos you you say how do I invest well
the more chaotic and more dangerous and
more uh messed up the world gets the
more people come to people like me for
clarity and guidance and solutions so
yeah that's my ultimate leverage you
said that you wanted to lead the why for
people that might later be canceled how
do you how do you feel that you're doing
that
because the pressure is already behind
the dam the dam of the social media
companies YouTube Instagram Etc they
have these monopolies the pressure is
behind the dam everybody knows they're
unfair and tyrannical nobody's happy
with them the problem is if you're
canceled there's nowhere else to go
I am proving that that's not the case
that when you're canceled you can move
to Alternative platforms and if you have
a true following they will follow you by
approving and that's going to put a
crack in the dam because now people are
going to say ah well if I could cancel
those go there and I think if I crack
the dam the pressure will do the rest
and then things are going to change I
don't I didn't want war with these
social media companies I didn't want to
have a genuine problem with them but
they decided that I'm unsafe for some
reason
perhaps I'm I'm optimistic in this
particular circumstance but I believe
that the social media companies will
eventually understand that they made a
mistake and as public sentiment shifts
they're going to offer me reinstatement
it doesn't matter to me either way but I
do think that is coming
but um
all in all yeah it never it never really
concerned me it was semi-inconvenient
yeah sure for a while and they close
your bank and stuff yeah yeah they close
bank accounts Payment Processing they
it's yeah unless I mean own the money
right yeah your your bank account but
they didn't take your properties off you
well they can yes exactly but that's
because of how I've set things up right
so you need to be smart on how you do it
yeah do it through a company well that's
right but I also think that Joe schmoe
who's just starting off buying his house
doesn't do a smart absolutely you know
what though in the UK they've devastated
landlords the taxes everything they're
killing landlords but the rich
corporations that are investing in
property the way they're doing it it's
very profitable completely and so the
small guy needs to learn how the big
guy's doing it and duplicate it yeah and
it's always been the same what did I say
earlier about the tax they don't come
after Rich they go after people
somewhere in the middle yeah
um but yeah like I think just especially
in England
which is the idea you hear people say
once we pay the mortgage off we'll be
we'll be it's just this fantasy and I
just yeah you know what I see when I
watch your videos and they're very fun I
I send them to my wife and she sends
them back you know they're very funny
and I know that sometimes you lean into
you deliberately piss people off yeah
you've said that but the big message
that I see is personal responsibility oh
completely take control of your mental
health take control of your physical
your physical
um abilities your weight your finances I
think that is what you're about it is
what I'm about because nobody else is
going to wake up and care more about
your life than you if you won't wake up
every day and say I need to get rich
nobody else is going to wake up and say
I need to make him Rich yeah nobody else
is going to do it for you so if you
don't think it nobody else is going to
think it which means nobody thinks it so
it's down to you right only you're the
person you're the only person on the
planet who can think it and I always
knew I never doubted for a second I
would be what I am I knew I would be
rich I just knew I would be rich and and
be free and be able to do and say what I
wanted I just knew that I was just like
there's no way
that guy in the Ferrari who drove past
me is a better person than me there's no
way he's smarter than that and I was not
arrogant because arrogance prevents you
from working arrogance makes because
I'll make it arrogance is to people who
go my ship will come in later arrogance
to the people who watch Love Island and
go I'll be rich later that's arrogance
most people are very arrogant I was
never arrogant I understood okay I'll
just outwork him maybe he's smarter than
me fine ah working I'm just not working
no problem boom let's get to work I
think that
a lot of people the main reason people
aren't aren't
Rich there's probably three primary
reasons
they're either lazy or arrogant or
they're stupid
I think lazy is actually quite a small
contingent because I think a lot of
people get out here and they work very
hard to a degree like even if you're a
trash man that's still work you're
working hard you're just not making any
money and also I think if you could show
somebody how to make money a lot of
people would would do it I don't think
they're that lazy if you say look press
this button for money they're not gonna
go no I don't want but can't be bothered
all right okay they're just lazy to find
out how perhaps but once they know how
they'll do it
stupid I think is also a very small
percentage I think that stupid is a
small percentage because I don't think
that IQ in fact it's been proven IQ has
nothing to do with how successful you
are very rich people very smart people
are broke yeah very dumb people are rich
like so I don't think that stupid is the
reason people aren't Rich the reason 98
of people aren't rich is because they're
arrogant
they are brutally arrogant and I say
that because you will stand up and say
I'm going to do a uh an event and I'm
going to teach you how to make money
from Real Estate and people will look at
you with all your success and go
what does he know [ __ ] him
not not worth my time
you're the millionaire dang I'll sit
here and say I'll give you free tips on
how to make money online
you can sign up get a free email
newsletter yeah do you know I saw him on
Tick Tock he's full of [ __ ]
how arrogant genuinely arrogant in your
soul must you be as an individual to
look at people who are massively
successful with all the credentials and
all the proof for all the things they
talk about and believe for some reason
you're too good to listen to them yeah
that's just arrogance if Mike Tyson
walked in here and said he's been
teaching me how to punch even though I'm
already a kickboxing world champion I'd
listen it's Mike Tyson the Beethoven
walked in resurrected and walked into
the CHP piano I'd listen yeah but if I
sit there and say look this is how you
make money there's a large contingent of
people out here go yeah but you know
what Tate I don't like him
I didn't ask you to like me I'll tell
you how to make money like they're just
arrogant people are brutally arrogant
and it holds them back they refuse to
[ __ ] learn or listen to anything and
they're they're dummies a bunch of
[ __ ] dummies and arrogance is the
reason 98 people are dominating money
that's why they're just [ __ ] arrogant
stupid yeah very interesting is there
anything that you regret from you know
the last sort of six 12 months
no uh I don't operate in that frame yeah
anyway I don't believe in regret I just
want to frame I operate in secondly it's
I know I'm that guy that no matter what
happens to me I'll make it into a
positive yeah you can you talk about
being dumped in the middle of London in
your underwear and pulling it off I'm
the same you can dump me in the desert
by myself expecting me to dehydrate and
you'll end up seeing me on the High
Street in Lambeau next month to be like
how the [ __ ] did he yeah I'm that guy
I'm just that guy yeah so when they
tried to attack me with everything I
kind of felt excited I was like ah
interesting the game's getting fun again
yeah so um most rich people though if
they're self-made and they're starting
from nothing if you took everything away
they're gonna make it back oh completely
it's a matter of time yeah completely
um yeah so
it's it's I don't regret absolutely
anything I know that what I say is true
I truly believe everything I say I know
that I can help people if they're
prepared to learn and listen I know my
Network's fantastic I know my university
is fantastic I don't sell scams I don't
lie to anybody I live with a pure heart
I'm one of God's favorites God loves me
um because I show strength and courage I
think the devil is looking for weak men
it's it's the weak men of the world that
he uses to do his evil doings and
harnessing strength in all of its forms
is service to God whether including
Financial strength so
I I don't regret absolutely anything
I don't operate in that frame uh I think
that it's still people a lot of people
think that this is the end of me and
they don't understand this is absolutely
not only just the beginning
my only concern now is becoming too big
that's my concern I'm worried about
becoming too influential too big
um so I have to try and work on that a
lot of stuff the media said about you
just isn't true most people don't have
brains they read the headlines they read
things out of context and it's happened
to me in the past yeah and that's one of
the reasons why I wanted to interview
with you was because I know what it's
like to be completely misunderstood and
for the media to go after you it's
interesting that all the social media
channels and all the media seem to say
the exact same thing yeah they ban you
so they can lie about you so you can't
respond so you can't respond so they ban
you so they can lie about you what did I
say at the beginning I said by removing
the other side of the argument that
creates a false reality they create the
matrix by Banning me and not allowing me
to give context or tell the truth on
anything they get to lie about me and
create a complete false reality they get
to pretend I'm something I'm not or I've
done things I haven't done
and convince the NPCs of the world
that's the case
I do find solace in the fact that the
people who are stupid enough to believe
everything they read in the media
without doing any kind of Investigation
are also going to be punished by God
himself through having a terrible life
of of
austerity those kind of people who just
believe everything they read in the news
or the people who suffer the most in
this world because they're all the
people who are smart enough to break
outside of the Matrix they're for
they're firmly inside of it they are the
slaves so I I kind of feel good when
someone goes I read this and I believe
it all I'm like oh so if you believe all
that then you also believe all of this
so you're like [ __ ] so cool all right
bro you keep believing it I'm off I
gotta go in the I'm off to the yard so
um God already punishes them which is
fine but uh yeah it's it's kind of scary
to a degree I guess you could look at it
from that way and understand it's kind
of scary that there's people in the
world who have that much power you can
just silence you and then lie about you
and I'd also like to state that I do
think that 99 of people in the world in
my position would have some kind of
detrimental mental health effect yeah
for sure I I am fortunate that I am
iron-minded I'm also fortunate that I'm
extremely capable my network is capable
I'm physically capable I've had a very
hard life Etc but most people are not
prepared to be lied about in the media
without a voice to be threatened to have
thousands of emails of death threats to
have their family thousands of emails of
death threats to have investigative
journalists kind of work out where their
parents live to have journalists call up
all their ex-girlfriends saying if you
have a negative story about Andrew Tate
we'll pay 50 Grand that's effectively a
bribe that's effectively saying we're
getting 50 G's no evidence just make up
a story give us your picture
and that's I mean none of them did
because I'm a nice guy but you ask the
average man watching this they were to
call every single one of your exes and
offer them 50 G's you tell me not single
one would say all right [ __ ] it he's a
[ __ ] anyway like it's scary right to
a degree
I'm lucky on me but if I was the average
dude I'd be suffering from this crap but
the people who are in charge don't care
they don't give a [ __ ] and they don't
give a [ __ ]
one because it's personal but two also
in general the world doesn't give a [ __ ]
about men's mental health which is
another thing that we need to talk about
because they pretend they do they put
headlines and pretend they do and they
say we have to talk about men's mental
health Etc et cetera but when I come
along as a Bastion of strength and
inspiration for the Youth of the world
until men listen
being a normal man or an average Joe is
always going to suck
the only way to have a good life as a
man is to be exceptional in some Fields
here is how you do it you need to work
your ass off they delete me they want
men to stay depressed semi-depressed
miserable paying the taxes
just Rich enough to pay tax too broke to
do anything else yeah that's what
everyone that's where they want you so
they don't care about men's mental
health either they don't care how many
men kill themselves they don't give a
[ __ ] have you had many people message
you directly saying I'm really offended
or do you think it's more just the media
trying to make out the people yeah it's
a very vocal minority so at the height
of the absolute clown world
at the height of the circus there was
three or literally like three or four
weirdos who were emailing me on repeat
death threats and stuff but I had
hundreds of thousands of emails of
support are you suing these guys the
yeah so I'm I'm taking legal
repercussion I'm looking into it but um
but I know the ultimate Victory is just
my my Monumental success the ultimate
Victory the people are sitting there
going I thought we canceled this guy
yeah he's still here and everyone still
loves him I thought we I thought we lied
about him why didn't the LIE work so
that's the ultimate success but yeah
it's kind of crazy but
God doesn't give us battles that we're
not prepared to deal with and it's also
allowed me to emerge galvanized so I
learned that if they can take away my
Uber account and my bank account and my
payment processing and my air like
things I didn't even use in fact the
only people I replied to was Airbnb
Airbnb emailed me and said uh Mr Tay in
light of recent media coverage our
values and commitments to inclusion mean
you are no longer welcome to use the
platform something and it was signed by
a guy called David I remember seeing
David and I was getting all these emails
in the same day and the only one I
replied to was Airbnb I said bro
I haven't used Airbnb in about four and
a half years like why are you trying to
feel included Banning me I don't use
your website I I don't know they're just
trying to jump in on the bandwagon let's
ban him I don't book your [ __ ] I don't I
don't even remember making an account I
was I don't think I've ever stayed in
the Airbnb in my life I don't know why I
even had an account but they were
desperate to ban me for some reason
what's the what's the reason it's it is
a bit crazy because there's a lot of
people that are very famous that say a
lot of outrageous things I mentioned
this in a video that I did where I
mentioned you about like cardi B for
instance he used to drug men because she
sold her soul she's owned cardi B is
owned record companies own her she's
paid money by sponsorship Brands Etc she
has meetings in private rooms where
people tell her what to say what
narratives to take she is on she's an
owned individual I'm completely
independent and Sovereign which is why
when they destroyed or they attempted to
destroy all my financials I realized
that just like I said earlier you don't
own anything like you think you do I'm
in the position now where I'm building
my own bank
I thought okay [ __ ] the bags I'll build
one
so I'm not gonna talk about how I'm
doing that but I'm building my own bank
from the ground up I will start my own
bank the bank of Tate it sounds very
exciting yeah but that's how that's on
the way now that's what you have to do
right it's an island position we're like
I need to [ __ ] make a bank now so I
guess I better go get it done so I'm
gonna build my own bank and and that'll
be interesting when we talk about once
that's online and finished then in
future podcasts we can talk about what
it's like to Outer Banks so we're gonna
talk about that but um
yeah it's the The Matrix attacks and and
they want everyone to to march in
lockstep
I'm not going to do that I'm a logical
actor I'm a logical person I think
people have this idea out there that I'm
crazy or I'm some weirdo or I I don't
know I've heard some strange conspiracy
theories about myself but I'm obviously
a very logical person and truthfully the
The Meta point is that a lot of the
people who dislike me don't live lives
I'd want to live
so it's very easy for me to discredit
their thinking when someone goes I
you're wrong and I go well if I'm wrong
but I get to be me
and you're right but you get to be you
perhaps being wrong is fine that's
interesting because a lot of them are
not living existences I could tolerate
so the most of my biggest haters I can I
can glance at and go
cool I would never adopt their thinking
because why would I want to think like
somebody who I don't want to be when you
were on YouTube do you know what your
ratio was of men and women no idea I
never had them never checked never
checked and I never had a monetized
video so I I was given YouTube billions
and billions of views I never even
monetized my videos I didn't monetize
any of it because I didn't think they'd
even let me in fact when I had 100 when
I first got 100K Subs I subscribed I I
requested my plaque you know you get
that plaque oh yeah yeah they said no
interesting they're like no sir then
they banned me so um I yeah what's your
message to the women because a lot of
you a lot of your videos seem very much
kind of aimed at guys yeah
I've got a property company I've also as
you know got a training company 50 of my
customers yeah are women good
killing it in property absolutely
absolutely smashing it my wife is my
business partner amazing we've been
married eight years happily married
perfect brilliant marriage yeah good
she's helped me get a lot richer yeah
we're business partners
do you think that your message and I
know you're not this crazy person that
the media make out yeah but do you not
think that the way you are you know
referring to women as [ __ ] do I refer
to women's [ __ ] yes you do okay well
first things first let's talk about that
if I if I make a joke or I say oh yeah I
I can't you have to give an example
where I even say that because I don't
think I say that publicly but or I don't
think I say that often but every rap
song says women are [ __ ] anyway like
I'm not saying that it's okay to say and
I'm not saying that I view women that
way but I'm to sit here and say that I
call women [ __ ] when every single
song on the radio is talking about
stabbing people and calling women
[ __ ] is kind of hypocritical I don't
I don't call women [ __ ] anyway I
don't think I do I you'd have to give me
a very specific example of that
I'm very sure I don't do you think that
your attitude maybe or the way that you
come across towards women is a little
bit maybe insulting towards women or you
know I know you inspire a lot of man
yeah 50 of my audience are women and I
want to train them up and Empower them
as well so I'm I'm mindful of I
understand you understand what I'm
saying yeah I think people who watch my
content in its long form understand that
I talk about being a protector and a
provider for women yeah you do I
truthfully believe that men and women
are very different I don't think we're
the same I think we're very different I
don't think one is better than the other
I just think that the reason the world a
lot of the problems we're in today is
based on the fact that we're forgetting
that men and women are slightly
different I think a lot of the problems
can be brought back to that very simple
point I think women are better than men
at a lot of things
I think men are better than women at
some things and that's what I say yeah
and I say in some scenarios I would
trust a man and in some scenarios I
trust a woman and I don't believe
they're interchangeable and exactly the
same
and I think in most of the world that's
accepted as complete truth in most of
the world they'll accept that woman is
better at this and a man is better at
this and if you work together you're a
perfect partnership and harmony
I don't mean to be disparaging or
insulting to women
but I will say the truth I will tell the
truth I will I will not sit and lie to
the world I'll say what I truly believe
I just think we'll do different things
and I think that that's how the world
Works in most of the world today when it
comes to business business listen men
make money women make money making women
making money fine men have advantages
women have advantages business just
proves my point further the advantages
that women have in business are
different than the advantages men have
in business I knew when I was in sales
jobs women who were very beautiful who
did fantastic in sales they could use
Beauty and going on that they could get
all the appointments they wanted oh it
was hard for me to get a guy to come to
dinner they could get the dinners they
could get the dinners all day I don't
know how good they were at sales they
may not have been as good as some of the
other people in the office but they got
so many more leads that they closed more
her Adventure her advantages were
different than the man's advantages
right so
saying that men and women are different
is not disparaging or insulting to
either one of them
there's been I've been making videos on
the internet for a long time
sure I can't sit here and honestly say
because I'm a professional I don't lie I
can't sit here and honestly say I didn't
say at some point hey this [ __ ] came
in with this [ __ ] when I'm telling a
story I probably did say that but I tell
you I insult men just as much just the
same it's not gendered and if you watch
my my stories I probably say this [ __ ]
was running her mouth I probably do say
that I also say in this dick I got hit
so it's not about man and woman it's
just about some people are [ __ ] and
idiots that's that's what it's about
it's not about it's not gendered about
men and women all the women who are in
my life and any woman who's anywhere
near me is very protected very provided
for
it's a traditional gender role where I
believe that all the money making
responsibility is on me now if I met a
woman who was making a bunch of money
I'm not gonna be like damn it stop
I feel good yeah do it but it's just
it's interesting that with my training
business yeah
50 of women yeah you know and and
they're smashing it well I think that
women would also be very very good at
property obviously I don't know anything
about it like you but I think when it
comes to things like interior design or
taking the time to be more meticulous
about how it particularly looks
decorating that I'm talking sales
systemization marketing amazing amazing
well and my wife when we when I got
married my net worth was about 500 Grand
within seven years of being married my
net worth was 20 million we're business
partners no but it's good to have but
I've never said women can't make money
and I've never said that women like in
my university is full of women there's a
bunch of women inside yeah there's women
inside my house I wouldn't say 50 yeah
maybe 20 percent
because I appeal to men with my my
advertise you have a daughter
I if I had children I would not be able
to stay on the internet I could have
three I could have ten what do you think
about the world economic forum
bro you're trying to get me suicided no
I did a video recently about the worldly
comic Forum it had to show off a million
views on YouTube and um a lot of
interesting comments yeah I think it's
very coincidental that every single
leader of all the important countries in
the world seems to come from the world
economic Forum so I encourage people at
home to do their own research along with
fractional Reserve Banking and mortgage
and interest rates and everything else
look up you know I tried to join the
world equipment Forum did you it's half
a million pounds a year I offered to pay
them and they did declined that's a
shame it would have been interesting
yeah
not only so you have to sell your soul
to one degree or another and that's the
thing was scary about those
organizations because if you did join it
I said this on another podcast so I'll
say it again at the height of my fame I
start getting very strange invites yeah
I start getting weird invites yeah from
a friend of a friend of a friend who had
like a private island in Greece or a
friend of a friend of a friend who's in
this private event it was always on
private islands very private like 10
guys 400 girls it was and I thought
maybe this is just debauchery and
degeneracy but maybe also they're gonna
drug my drink or there's cameras in the
everywhere or you don't know this stuff
and they get leverage over you so I was
I was saying no to all of it but if I
was a degenerate individual and sex
hungry or whatever like a lot of these
celebrities are they end up getting
leverage over you and and then you're in
real trouble then you have to shut up
and they tell you to shut up world's
scary man but um
yeah after the wef well we can like I
said I encourage everyone to do their
own research but uh yeah back to the
woman's point I don't think women can't
make money I don't know I I and I'm not
surprised that half of the women who
work for you who work with you make a
bunch of money I'm not surprised like I
said about 20 of the people inside of my
University are women I think that my
advertising style is more geared to men
because I talk about men's issues but
the reason I talk about men's issues is
because I'm a man why would I sit here
and talk about how hard it is to be a
girl I can talk about why I think it's
difficult to be a girl but I can't talk
about growing up as a girl
because I'm not a girl
I might have just misgendered myself
sorry YouTube but I'm not a girl I don't
know and so have you got like one
girlfriend who you see as a life partner
I hope I don't understand get you in
trouble with your girlfriends that watch
this at home I'm a man of God I'm a
Christian man and I live true but
Christianity believes in marriage bro
that's it yeah I'm married then
I mean you live with your brother don't
you how does that work out is that like
a long term when you're 60 70 you're
gonna live with your bro and be sleeping
with loads of young girls
I wouldn't say yeah okay first first
thing I don't know what you mean by
Young
um attractive yeah and attractiveness
and youth are linked to a degree
but yeah I will be living with my
brother forever because I think that uh
masculine competition is a healthy
environment for to bring out the best in
yourself if you look at any fighter
who's training for a fight he's not
going to live with his wife he's going
to live with other men you're gonna live
the last few weeks before a fight Mike
Tyson whatever would move away from
their wife and live with in a house with
just guys like it's kind of like the
Army mentality it's good for your
mentality if you want to be the absolute
Peak version of yourself
I think that you can achieve that by
being in a competitive environment with
other competitive men if I live with
just a woman which sometimes obviously I
do if I stay with a woman it's very
comfortable it's very comfortable it's a
great place like just food she's nice
let's watch TV oh calm down don't worry
it's very comforting place which is
great but I don't think that Comfort
brings out the Best in Me whereas if I
live with my brothers like I've just
done 600 push-ups you're a [ __ ] then I
have to do 601. maybe
602.600 he's interested and then and
that's it and there's competitiveness if
I'm if I'm hanging with my boys and
we're all talking about how much money
we made that week it pisses me off I'm
gonna hang on my girl we don't talk
about that really or if we do we're on
the same team so it's different you
cannot think that to be the to be the
best version of yourself you need
competition well without competitiveness
without competition how are you going to
be the best version of yourself right
you're always going to do better and and
run further and push harder against
someone else so having that friendly
competitive element is how you become
the best version of yourself so that's
why I like living with my brother for
that reason do you not think though if
you found
a woman who you could be your business
partner with and do not think that can
you never say just getting married being
with one woman having kids having a
family home living close to your brother
my brother lives too many walk away from
me we're business partners he's got his
family I got my family does that not
appeal to you at all is there nothing
about that where you think you know what
maybe
God has a plan yeah we will see yeah
what do you want to be remembered for
um God also has a plan for that I think
I think I'm going to be remembered
positively I've not snaked anyone I've
not lied to anyone I don't lie to people
I don't scam people I don't do anybody
harm I try my very very best to live a
peaceful life I think I'll be remembered
for being one of the first major voices
in the breaking of the big Tech Monopoly
that's going to be exciting
since I've moved over to rumble the
world's already began to change in real
time Russell Brand's now moved over
Steve will do it one of the note boys
and big twitch streamers big YouTubers
were all moving over I started all of it
in a month ago yeah
um and they've just gone public
so that's dollar sign rum on the NASDAQ
I think across the next 10 years as
YouTube continued their censorship
especially with the elections coming up
and these kind of things and they
continue their censorship and people get
more and more tired of it they're gonna
be moving to Alternative platforms so I
think Rumble stocks can go to the Moon
there's a tip for everyone looking to
make money
that'll make me a billionaire
and uh I don't want to do buy more cars
yes what is it what is it that you love
about cars so much because you have what
28 supercars how much I Googled how much
it is to Barbie got say
I could not believe it because I thought
oh yeah mine's not a normal one how much
did you pay for it by the time I got it
on the road with everything 5.2 damn how
do you justify that
it's beautiful
I'd rather have to carve than the money
that's how I justify it I'm at the point
now where I used to love them because I
I love to drive and I live in Romania
where they have beautiful mountain roads
and there's no real speed limits at my
level of of influence so I can drive
however I want the whole place is like a
race track right and I just my hobby
would just be if I ever took time off
work would just be to drive three four
hours to the mountains stay in a nice
hotel Drive I just love to drive around
Europe I drive to the Alps drive through
Switzerland but
um now now I'm kind of too busy to drive
so now I just buy them because
when I say money isn't real
I'll give an example
before I was too famous to walk the
street
every time I walked past an ATM I would
get out as much as I could I'd get the
maximum cash
also the girls a couple years ago she
goes why do you do that and I said
because it's free money because why is
it free money I was like because if my
bank balance is 17 184938
and I go get 900 quid out and at 17
932-914 I don't know the math
it looks the same it's the same but I
don't understand now
waste it so the money's free and the
point even though obviously is not free
the number's been reduced but it doesn't
affect the number it I can it looks the
same so you get to a point where money
has no value at all it's not real so if
something goes to me there's a new
Ferrari
do you want it and I think
do I want it
one maybe I might one day look at it and
go that's nice that's worth 500 Grand to
me to just look at it and go it's a nice
car on the driveway
that's work that's worth it because
because the money has no value so it's
like well [ __ ] it then everything is
free I I try to explain this to people
what it's like to be really truly truly
rich everything is free nothing has a
price
no matter what I want it's basically
free outside of Mega yachts and the most
expensive properties on the planet
everything is free so it's just do I
want something at all even if I only
want it one percent I'll take it the
hotel I stay in in London
I stay in it and let's say it's supposed
to be two and a half thousand pounds a
night I get a suite every time for nine
thousand pounds a night because the
shower head is different I like the
shower head a shower head is worth seven
G's a night to me because the money has
so it's it's the money is so invaluable
that tiny things are worth everything
does that make I don't know how else to
explain it yeah the world's free I just
walk around and I just everything's free
do I want it a tiny bit Yeah and then so
we'll just take it then because the
money doesn't mean anything that's kind
of how it feels you get to a certain
level of wealth that's why I say money's
not real it's not real none of it's real
and uh
another thing I will quickly say people
say what's the coolest thing about being
rich the the three the three coolest
things about being rich I will say oh
there's three there's three
one
because and it's only fun because I get
to compare it to the broke days is
eating whatever I want and I know that
sounds stupid but like going into a
restaurant and going I want all four of
those things that sounds good give me
all four I'm having a little bit of each
one and then [ __ ] it off just having
thousands of pounds bills of food that's
the first thing that's cool the second
thing that is absolutely and oddly a
life hack is time travel is private jets
I could not go back to Flying normally
it it changes private jets change the
world how much does it cost when you
when you go on a plane if I fly from
London to Bucharest 40 Grand okay so
it's not crazy it's not crazy but like I
do it two or three times a week or two
miles a month I spend half a million a
month on Jets probably because because
it allows you to time travel do you plan
to buy your own jet there's advantages
and disadvantages to that I was thinking
about doing it but truthfully a lot of
the time especially in the summer I
drive around Europe right so if I drive
from Bucharest to Switzerland now I've
got to fly my plane empty there and find
the staff and it's easier just to get to
Charter One yeah but the reason private
jets are cool is because they're time
travel because you you remove all the
[ __ ] either end with the airport
so what I'll often do
like I left book I left my house at 901
this morning I remember seeing 901 I
drove to the airport private terminal 9
15 I got there I there's nobody in there
so three minutes through just passport
security everything I was on the jet by
9 20.
and then because there's a two-hour time
difference I landed in England at 10 30.
that's crazy I left my house at nine I'm
in England by 10. convenience speed yeah
so if this interview ends now and I
decide I want to go home I can make a
phone call and I can be home in time for
bed it's a two or two and a half hour
flight to book rest but it takes two and
a half hours to get in out Central
London to car most the time yeah so it's
like time travel yeah so jets are super
cool because they're time travel because
you could the number of times I've gone
to four countries in a day boom
interview boom boom boom boom I go check
Republic Warsaw Germany Austria on a day
that's cool food's cool private jets are
cool and the only other thing that's
really cool is you realize that the rich
people of the world have done very good
in convincing that poor people of the
world that rich people aren't happy yeah
they've done a great job of that so true
they say oh he's rich but he's probably
miserable yeah
why doesn't he give his money away then
have you ever seen a rich person give
all their money away I haven't have you
I mean anybody is miserable the money's
not making him miserable like maybe it's
something else of course money can't buy
happiness I agree but money is the third
most important thing in the world first
is your relationship first is your
health because you have nothing if
you're going to die second is your
relationships because you need love and
family that matters the most but money
can buy everything else so money is the
third most important thing but
um
using your money to have relationships
and friendships are amazing for me I
think that knowing I have friends who
live in Japan but we can say [ __ ] it
let's let's meet up let's meet up oh
you're in Japan okay cool Maldives
it's that's cool yeah the money allows
you to be closer to people I have more
friends because I'm rich not less I have
more friends I have better relationships
I think a lot of people who argue you
saying your marriage is fantastic that's
good I think a lot of marriage arguments
are about money yeah it's true I think a
lot of them are yeah so people say oh
he's rich but he's not happy I bet if
you were Rich you'd have a better
relationship with your woman I bet you'd
have a less stressful time at home you'd
have more friends like it's amazing for
for relationships that's the coolest
thing about one of the reasons why I
probably haven't argued because even
though I wasn't rich I was still worth
half a million I was doing okay
completely and then we've we've not
we've not been short it's just another
source of stress isn't it yeah it is
yeah so it's another thing not to write
about yeah talk to me about this demand
because when I when I went to Beverly
Hills I hired some supercars yeah
because I'm not a massive Car Guy okay
so I got like a Lamborghini yeah had it
for about a week then I got a Ferrari
and personally I know you love driving
fast than that yeah
the speed bumps
couldn't even reach
just enjoying my Range Rover yeah um so
maybe I'm missing something maybe it's
an acquired no no it depends on the
country in America for sure I agree with
you in America I wouldn't even have cars
another thing is this sorry tried to cut
you sure like when we last met yeah your
car bro it's true like you literally I
had to put a brand new I had to pick you
up in my Range Rover I know I had a
brand new limited edition 1100
horsepower portion it wouldn't start but
it wouldn't start and then literally you
were messing around faffing around and
I'm thinking you know what I can't be
doing with this I want my big fat range
that massages me and has a fridge in it
I'm done well I have both I've arranged
too I've arranged too but um no but no
you're right but every everything that's
beautiful in life comes with headache
it's kind of like all right a lot
sometimes my cars mess up and their
headache and I try and explain it like
if you get a beautiful girlfriend
sometimes she's headache you get a
beautiful car sometimes this headache
yeah that's life right but
um yeah like they're a hobby now but
Romania and Europe I think it's
beautiful to drive in and maybe it comes
back into that old story of me saying
seeing the guy in the Ferrari it's kind
of funny
I have another similar story probably
the last story I'll tell I told about
the Ferrari driving past me in college I
gave him another story I was selling TV
advertising
and I had a meeting in Seven Oaks Kent
on a Monday morning to goes down the
cell television advertising and on
Sunday afternoon I was eating in Nando's
in Luton in the Galaxy Center and I
watched a van I watched it happen I was
eating and I saw a van just reversing I
just watched it reverse into my car
I was like you're [ __ ] kidding me I
went out there he gave me Insurance
details whatever but the front of my car
is messed up now yeah
but I had this meeting so I had to drive
this busted BMW down to this meeting I
just thought I'll park far away so the
guy doesn't see my broken car because
I'm selling something prestigious TV
advertising is expensive it's Prestige
you can't go it's not anymore but it was
back then so I'm driving my broken BMW I
get to Ken just went along the M25
whatever
and I'm sitting there at the traffic
lights at about 10 a.m on a Tuesday
morning and this Aston Martin pulls up
next to me with the roof down and I had
a Swedish number plate Sweden and it was
a guy and this blonde chick and they
were blaring music and I was sitting
there in my BMW with a broken front and
I kind of didn't want to give him any I
didn't want to look because I want to
make him feel good I kind of glanced and
I thought this prick he's from Sweden
why is he in Ken where did he come from
it's Tuesday he's listening to music
he's got this hot chick he ain't going
to work he ain't what's he doing and I
here I am to this broken car you know I
went to the meeting didn't even get the
deal blah blah long story short maybe
that's kind of like world going full
circle because now I drive through
Romania yeah and and and I have a hot
chick next to me in my Lambo or my
Bugatti or my Ferrari or whatever and
the Romanian kid looks at me and goes
this English guy in this Lamborghini
with this hot chick he ain't going to
work it's kind of like the the world's
like I'm now him yeah it's kind of cool
from that perspective maybe that's why I
love cars I don't know a lot of my a lot
of my stories on me realizing how the
Matrix needs to be broken we're
semi-related to cars because when you
start seeing a car the price of a house
and then you start seeing people with 30
of them that's gonna wake you up that's
got to wake you up that I try and say
this to people let's imagine what's
what's a good wage in england 100 Grand
a year 100 Grand year 100 good wage yeah
what's that on on 100 Grand what you're
paying 40 or 50 tax probably about 40
okay so let's say you get 60 Grand a
year let's imagine you're earning 100 a
year you're successful
inside of the Matrix you're a successful
slave
you make 60 Grand a year let's imagine
you can live for free eat for free you
walk to work you never buy clothes just
imagine you save 100 of your money 60
Grand each year
I don't want to do the math off the top
of my head but my Bugatti was 5.2 what
is that is that like 90 years it's a
lifetime of saving that's a lifetime of
slave work without spending a penny ever
once to by the time you're a [ __ ]
geriatric and can't function you might
be able to buy one of my 30 cars if that
does not tell you the Matrix must be
cracked and there's other ways to make
money then nothing [ __ ] will because
if you think you're just gonna work your
way to the top and just stick to the
rules you're a dummy no you won't you'll
find modern wealth creation methods you
need to hack real estate like you've
obviously done I teach how to do it my
way inside of Hustler's University which
is on covertake.com
or you need a strong Network you can't
just be sitting here thinking I'll just
it'll just happen one day because no it
[ __ ] will not because you're
competing against men like me and we're
taking it all what was it that made you
agree to sit down with myself I knew we
had some opposing viewpoints which have
come out yeah and no but it makes it
better that way yeah than agreeing on
everything I know we had some of using
proposing viewpoints so I thought it'd
be good to me
um when I come to London I like to stay
busy you know uh I don't do anything
leisurely here I think that London is a
failed Society I'll say that on camera I
think that's falling apart in real time
I think by every metric it can be
measured by in terms of
the cost of things the crime rate the
general happiness index of the people
how often the trains are late how dirty
the streets are anything you can measure
London is failing
so when I come here it's purely just
business obligations
and uh I knew we'd have an interesting
talk so I thought well let's let's go
and meet Samuel well it's been very
interesting enjoyable I appreciate your
time cheers bro stay in touch thanks bro
thank you